[Laughter]
hey it's us again it's friday
zach's [ __ ] gay ass in there y'all
being sweet and [ __ ] cussing people
early in the don't cuss my customers
exactly
early on
call my customers a bunch of [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
come down here and straighten your ass
out i like the way you just call like
his gay ass the rest of him is not gay
no just it's just
that's the only part that matters that's
the only part that matters
he walked walking coming straight at
your ass first
[Laughter]
let the daddy outfit on man i'm
dominating right now i'm dominating
you've even got your uh which one is
your bracelet over there you don't have
that on you is that for later yeah i'm
[ __ ] naked
you're naked there you go yeah it's like
i was like why did you leave that over
there yeah you go and i think your [ __ ]
sucker hat is back there so that's all
right that's i'm not i'm not [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] uh fired up yet okay i'm not
fired up yet that when the time he's not
firing he's only firing on one cylinder
zach says that's because tom wants this
ass but he ain't getting this ass
because he ate my time
just trying to play hard to get first
thing in the [ __ ] morning when i
[ __ ] wake up and start my work my job
is this when you wake the first thing
when you wake up in the morning yeah
went to the signing ceremony got this
[ __ ] signed the signing ceremony
did they put a crown on you and [ __ ] yes
in this year now
got the house yeah and then um don't
have to pay rent don't have to pay
mortgage this month
yeah because it was all folded into the
[ __ ] i was like that's good because and
get some cushions yeah
i said [ __ ] that [ __ ] i swung by [ __ ]
sam's and bought a ice maker and a
little refrigerator for upstairs
so we don't have to go downstairs
we're about to get ice and juice
don't have to worry about the ice
buckets i've got a gallon of filtered
water you just pour it in the top and it
just makes more ice than you can drink
and then turn the [ __ ] off it's about
it's really fast it makes it like 15
minutes 15 minutes it makes a whole
glass on what is time to be alive yeah
oh my goodness
how does one get a little blue admin
wrench next to their name
make it make you a moderator wait you
want to be a moderator you're asking for
this grant there's hammer
you can be a moderator if you want to be
it's a lot i think i might have the it's
a lot of i don't have i don't have the
authority you guys it's a lot of
responsibility yeah what you want one
you want one yeah okay i'm going to make
um
wait add the moderator there we go yeah
and there you go you're promoted
put a star neck does that i mean you
know if you want one if you want to do
it
now we'll see because when he came up
again i'm not really sure let's see what
she left the [ __ ] heater wrong
why is this man that [ __ ] [ __ ] hot i
didn't turn the heat off in there you
turned the heater on yet yesterday it
was cold
i never turned the heat on i don't like
having the heat on
it makes it makes me
like feel like i'm suffocating yeah so
if the heat was on you did that [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
it wasn't me because i got up well i got
up this morning and i was like wow it's
kind of hot in here i wonder if he's
still on but then i started working and
i forgot about it
and uh then you came home and you're
like it's hot in here i was like i think
you left the heat on and he's like oh
yeah i did yeah
[Laughter]
missed time getting an ice maker i
didn't even know that they made
little it's like essentially like a
desktop ice maker yeah it's like the
size of a bread maker yeah and you just
pour water in it and then it turns on
and it's like just makes [ __ ] ice i'm
like holy crap yeah it looks like a
popcorn maker yeah i didn't know all
this [ __ ] existed and you just pour
water in the top of it i'm gonna i pour
filtered water in it because he's faith
because i'm fancy
and i think i'll just sit there and make
ice until until it runs out of water to
put it in a big basket
i think it'll fill the basket up
which will do probably about one-third
of the of the water and then it turns
itself off and then you gotta take some
out of the basket
and it'll continue to make ice whenever
you turn your back on it it makes ice if
you watch it it won't make ice
[ __ ] senses you're watching it it
gives performance anxiety
that's like you're looking it's hard
yeah it's like the watch pot never boils
down too hard
it's not gonna rock up the ice will not
rock up rocks will not fall it's like
having a guy next to you in the urinal
i'm told
with the wood will not rise stop looking
at my wings
you're watching you're looking at it too
hard
i feel it
i feel the optical [ __ ] hitting it
it's like a laser
yeah
well there's this myth
that somebody's going into your eye
that's been disproven it's actually
coming out
that's how quantum physics works yeah
that's how you
i want laser eyes you know how the
[ __ ] now the [ __ ] that that little
that thing then quantum physics you know
the the the the observer effects or
whatever yeah yeah that's how it knows
it reaches out and touches it
reach out and touch the quantum
particles they're vision part particles
it's 2a was that bell south that little
jingle i don't know
that's like
i'm so old cheryl says uh heat on in
florida well that's what i said oh it
got cold here in past couple days it did
about 30 something i mean yeah it's not
like not real arctic cold but it was
right it was hovering around freezing i
like that though i just love like hey
more blankets i'm like sammy dade county
put out a following iguana warning
[ __ ] did you hear about that a
following iguana warning it was getting
so cold that people had to [ __ ] watch
out for falling iguanas
because they're because they'd freeze
and fall out of they get out of the
trees and they don't die
but they uh they don't distinguish
yeah they go into hibernation
and they got antifreeze in them but
they'll fall out and they'll hit people
they're big
and they said if they hit if they said
don't throw them away they're not dead
lead them up against the tree it'll be
all right
they said don't throw the [ __ ]
iguanos away because they got people
from new york moved down here to miami
and they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing they they've never their
feet have never even been off a concrete
before so when they see something like a
[ __ ] iguana fall out of a tree it's
rock solid
in their minds it's dead
it's not dead well i mean most people
would probably think that to be fair
they got to put out warnings that is not
a dead iguana don't throw it away
and it'll warm right back this is an
ex-parrot but yeah so uh i used to have
a baby iguana like as a pet
and i had a gecko as well a tokay gecko
and yeah reptiles in general uh you know
obviously because they're cold-blooded
so their blood is the same temperature
as the outer egg they fall asleep and
they can't regulate yeah so they just go
into my gecko used to do that too if it
went under because my gecko you had to
put heat rocks and [ __ ] like that like
in his little house
and uh he liked it about 90 degrees so
i'm like well we're opposite on that
buddy but he really liked it hot and if
it went under
75 or something like that he just went
yeah and just sat there and didn't move
yeah well they'll fall out of trees
they'll hit people because the wind
blows them out they can't hold on
they get into a place where they'll just
rest on a limb gravity will hold them
there
but you know when to blow them off and
hit people and the walking paths
underneath it they're in between the uh
the apartment buildings you know
up in the trees oh it's starting to go
red [ __ ] no no no
please don't do it now it's got beds
back okay it's back this is i'm gonna be
really mad if this [ __ ] does this
again i'll reset that router if we okay
we lose the stream
we will be right back i'll go down there
and reset the route yeah we're not gonna
i mean the only reason that we stopped
on wednesday night was because literally
i only have it i had one story left and
it was really short and i was like look
i'm not restarting the whole thing just
for that just for another like five or
ten minutes so
do not taunt falling frozen iguana or
happy fun ball uh don't throw away your
iguanas yeah my poor little iguana um
apparently if you get an iguana when
they're a baby which means my sister had
one
they're really really hard to keep alive
they're kind of like delicate you know
what i mean little critters if you get
one when they're grown up i guess it's
easier but
yeah he got sick and
he uh committed suicide actually by eat
by eating a bunch of um
there was like all this kind of litter
at the bottom of his
tank yeah uh you know it was the right
kind but like all the pellet litter and
he ate so much of it that he thought he
thought it tasted good i guess he
thought it was food i don't know
yeah poor little guy well he's locked up
yeah
you know i don't like any i don't like
to keep any kind of pets that you have
to keep confined
even i kind of worry about
[ __ ] fish and fish tanks
it depends on the kind of fish i think
some fish don't mind it but i mean if
they're normally their normal
environment is you know not that big
like a fighting fish
yeah
well everybody used to like we used to
win them at fairs right
and now i feel kind of bad because when
i was a kid like you'd get one and then
you'd be like hold a mirror up to the
tank and he'd be like and he'd like try
to get the other fish and stuff then i'm
like that's kind of mean that's all but
they'll just wait around in the damn paw
print and a wet paw print jump from one
paw print to the next and in the wild
they live in mud really
and if they see anything else that's a
any other kind of male they attack it
that's all they have to do though
they have to attack that's it and sit
around in a damn
yak footprint filled with water
yeah they can't read they don't have
like little fish books or anything like
that
or the internet but how cute would that
be like them having tiny little laptops
if you put a better built for their
little fins if you put them in a bigger
bowl they stress out and die
yeah
it's too much room they jump out they'll
jump out and try to leave you'll find
them at this i try to [ __ ] this place
[Music]
sit there driving out i had some aquatic
frogs that you can't do that and throw
them back in there and he's like oh [ __ ]
i'm back it's like for them it's
probably like an episode of the twilight
zone
i keep handing up back in here
it's like groundhog day yeah what's
happening oh my god because they don't
they don't belong here
they're blowing out from vietnam or
wherever it is they come from
murder horror turn says my baby one i'm
assuming iguana got a respiratory
infection and died yeah that's i think
that's pretty common with uh with pet
ones that's what i read afterward they
said if you get one when it's an adult
then they're pretty hardy
but when they're babies they uh don't
adapt well to captivity don't iguanas
eat insects
yes but um
they do but they you can feed them uh
fruit vegetables stuff like that they'll
eat lettuce bananas they'd all that kind
of stuff too but you do have to give
them like crickets or some [ __ ] like
that
you know i had a um my gekko
he didn't really eat pretty much all he
ate was bugs and worms like he he
wouldn't eat like fruit or anything like
that so i had to raise crickets and
mealworms which was
nice but i had to have so i had his big
tank and then i had a bunch of tanks of
crickets and mealworms next to it that i
had to keep throwing in there but they
roaches and all that kind of stuff i
don't know about iguanas they're more
vegetarian based
or something
uh and he says iguanas and tarantulas
run wild here yeah
so you know um let's see
yeah everybody's talking about how it's
supposed to snow
up in philly and new york
it's gonna snow that kind of sounds nice
it's not
how i think it was cooler today i think
that
it went up to 60 65
which is pretty cool for florida for
this time of year
although it's weird because on my
computer earlier i kept getting it was
like 65 degrees or whatever the hell and
then i kept getting a little freeze
warning and i'm like 65 degrees isn't
freezing i was like is it warning me
that it's gonna freeze tonight like hey
cover up your plants maybe i don't know
i don't know what it was doing
i just i'd never seen the freeze warning
come up before so i was like
i was mystified as to what it was
cheryl says we just have bears and moose
and wild turkey
we got bears yeah we got bears too
just you know black bears alligators
crocodiles i've seen wild turkeys around
here too actually
blossom raccoon
got all kinds of stuff otters yeah
otters alligators yeah
sandhill cranes
you're trying to get in your house
eagles i've seen a bunch of eagles since
i've been here bald eagles i don't know
why they come here
well you know where else are they gonna
go grantham's hammer said uh my my
nine-month-old britney spaniel is eating
her own turds
frozen ones in the yard
poopsicles
dogs are gross
they'll eat anything
don't some people like have if you have
a dog and a cat won't dogs eat cat turds
out of the out of the litter box
they're not even talking this way man i
don't want to talk about this
you guys don't talk about anything it's
pretty correct yeah
connor batson says guys have you ever
eaten roasted crickets with salt lime
and tequila no i have not no but that's
some mexican stuff here yeah senor stix
asked first if you had a harley and then
can you wrestle a bear and win oh i can
wrestle better win yeah i don't know
what kind of video
uh i got i got four bikes um they're all
customs that i built one of them isn't
complete
two of them are uh buells which are i
don't know if you know what a build is
it was it so it was a sport bike that
had a harley davidson base engine in it
got two of those
um
i got a uh
my dad's 1972 honda ct 70 that i rebuilt
it looks brand new i you i could enter
that that it's a little mini bike
i could enter that into a show and win
um
it's um
140 it's it's now 140 cc's with the uh
air with a oil cooler on it and a
megaphone style exhaust inverted front
end
suspension disc fronts aluminum wheels
fat [ __ ]
road race rubber on it
um super bike bars and it and a um
like in uh honda um
a honda [ __ ] um road race uh seat on
it
uh metal metal gas tank instead of the
internal plastic ones [ __ ] candy
apple green
it's beautiful
i got a video of it
um i was riding it around for a while it
was fast it it only weighed 45 pounds it
goes about 70.
it's real wicked
the thing is you can't go anywhere with
it it only carries about
a quart and a half maybe two about two
quarts of fuel and it burns it up in
about 20 miles
so you can't go too far you can't go
anywhere
oh just a show bike and a toy i got it
in the
got it into um my little man cave here
it's up here on the second floor because
i just carried around we had to carry it
up the stairs yeah
the other one i haven't didn't finish it
but it's a rolling chassis i have the
motor and everything it's it's just the
motor's got to be rebuilt before i
continue and there's some [ __ ]
bearings and some spacers that i'd have
to manufacture
it's a 1971
um yamaha rd350
with inverted front end
inverted front end dual discs
modern wheels and road race robbers
superbike bars
[ __ ] um superbike seat on it
it's got the
tank out of it off of a yamaha h2 from
1972.
um i got to repaint that tank but i got
the motor
and got the [ __ ]
the
the cylinders
the crankshaft
the pistons
uh
i got the transmission
all the gears but problem is is that the
crankshaft's got spun bearing and um
one of the cylinder heads has burned
through it's got to be replaced there's
work that has to be done on it
and uh rebuilding a two-stroke
crankshaft is [ __ ] tough not a lot of
guys know how to do it no some machine
tools that i would have to
buy in order to do it correctly
and i just kind of lost
i was going to put a banshee top end on
it
see
which would have made that thing about
90 horsepower
it'd have been a real wicked i just
don't know if i'm ever going to finish
the thing
i think it would have been a death trap
but i was done with it it wouldn't have
weighed anything you know
yeah tom's going to go sailing off of
[ __ ] over bats or something somewhere
i think probably would have weighed
about 200 pounds
probably weighed about 200 pounds maybe
because i know how you do yeah and he
tells me he doesn't go really fast on it
but i know he does and he doesn't tell
me
but it weighed about 200 pounds probably
about 100 horsepower probably because
that wreck you got in years ago you told
the first time i was like how fast were
you going up 45 and then later it was
maybe it was 65 so we're like about 70.
yeah
that's all right though i was like i
suspected as much i couldn't get out of
bed last day she's taking my clothes off
i was [ __ ] stiff as a board
that was when i used to work outside the
house that was a while back but um
yeah you called me and said you were in
a wreck and i was freaking out and i was
like well this is like i should come no
no don't come home i'm fine i'm fine and
so i get home and he's just like laying
in bed going ah
she had to feed me i brought him a big
mac yeah you guys i could barely eat and
i had to sit it on his cheeks and like
push it toward his back
he couldn't like i had to like take like
the pants of you to put like the
sweatpants on you yeah and he was just
all he had his armor and [ __ ] on but it
was still like he got really beat up i
was wearing a full set of [ __ ] icon
striker body armor
underneath my regular
armor
and uh you know i was wearing
jacket and pants and boots and yeah he
had all this i had all my [ __ ] on
and i only had road rash just in like
this one spot right here where there was
yeah
and uh
it's like getting beat up with a
baseball bat
you know just
that bruising was to the bone
and i pissed a little bit of blood for
the first couple hours but it went away
and i didn't say anything about it after
that i had a [ __ ] little bit of a
[ __ ] because i had been hit real bad
right here yeah got it in the kidneys
yeah it was probably 70. yeah every time
i asked him about it the speed got
higher and higher but i i mean i knew
you were a lion and the first time you
said that so you know what i mean
uh
i did that on the um
it's a mod it's a race modified buell
xb12 that's what i which is a 1203
[ __ ] little bitty bull air-cooled
real narrow little
sport bike that i built
and uh
it didn't do much damage to the bike i
had frame sliders and [ __ ] it said i was
actually shocked when i saw the bike
because it's like it was very little
damage yeah i had to replace frame
sliders that was it
um
and handlebar ends and stuff
bent up a clip on
it also took the controls out on the
left sides but really the in terms of
chassis and stuff it
you know the frame didn't had a big
frame bumper on the side it
it didn't have far to fall it just fell
over on its side and it was next to me
sliding next to me across the ground and
i was kind of
once i slowed down i was able to tumble
a little bit and i don't remember how i
[ __ ] got bird up so bad but you know
it's just it's happening so fast
yeah i hit a cat
yeah cat ran out in front of me and i
put the brakes on just as he was hitting
the front tire kind of did an endo and
lost it [ __ ] went into like a speed
wobble and came off
yeah it happened there was nothing you
can do just
it was like i was riding the next minute
the [ __ ] bike left me yeah i was
going through the air hitting on the
ground scary
i looked over like that
through that [ __ ] in the vision
through my helmet opening i looked and
saw the bike next to me sliding across
the ground next to me i was like oh [ __ ]
i was thinking about how much damage it
was doing to that thing
bye bye
he's like i don't give a [ __ ] about my
limbs
we have so much adrenaline
i know
uh cheryl says tom's a biker gang all by
himself
grantham's hammer says fill me in on the
rules of being an admin do i get to put
lippy viewers in timeout yeah and then
cheryl says if you have to put lippy
people in timeout tom would never be on
the show yeah
yeah i let them see what they want
i know most
most of the audiences is hoes you know
male and female we're all hosts
uh compared to me yeah mostly yellow
hoes
tom's sitting on a on a huge pile of
hoes yes it's
in a little throne it's all relative
relative onus it's all relative
theory of relative ownership
thank you for the super chat zach uh one
thing i've learned in life is you never
turn your back on the ocean bears or the
dominant turkey in mating season
probably uh geese too i kind of feel
like aren't geese kind of [ __ ] i've
never run into one but i've heard that
from a lot of people
tammy says i was thinking about making
the gumbo recipe out of your cookbook
does tom have any advice that is not in
the book
about gumbo i can't remember what kind
of meat are you going to use you can use
all different kinds of meat
my advice is um
as far as bang for the buck chicken
chicken is
chicken gumbo is a lot cheaper
if you can use sausage
sausage and chicken is good all right i
mean i kind of feel like it's got to
have sausage in it yeah
now you can't get andouille you can use
other kinds of sausages you know
if you can't find cajun sausage or
andouille you can use like country
sausage or
you know
trying to think what else works
it's just got to be like a
i don't know
what's the sausages you put on
cowboy it is a cowboy yeah i was gonna
say what are you talking about wait a
sausage on top of the sauce
i was thinking
like on a bun oh okay sometimes
polish sausage might work
yeah yeah
i mean if it was kind of similar yeah
it all just depends on
what your limit where you live and what
your limitations are so just not enough
i kind of feel like most grocery stores
nowadays usually have some kind of cases
sausage yeah or like a georgia sausage
or something it's not like it used to be
at least in the u.s i mean pretty much
any grocery store there's so many chains
like you can find almost anything yeah
it gets more ice holder
honestly man
i um i went to over to the dollar
general today
because i needed to get some uh some
minute maid and also
we're out of pooky's little meat stick
snacks and i ordered her some more but
they're not coming until later so i said
well i'm gonna go see if the dollar
general has any because she's getting
mad about it
she keeps trying to like climb into the
drawer where they were
and they didn't have those but they did
have this
it's temptations but they're not like
the crunchy ones they're kind of like
meat they're treats but they're like
like smooshy meat kind of so they're
like the sheba meat sticks but just in
little chunks but that [ __ ] dollar
general i didn't have a ton of time to
like walk around in there but holy crap
they have everything i was like [ __ ]
they even have like
um like cheap furniture and stuff like
that i said like they had little um
little side tables and they had like a
set of shelves like for 18 bucks like
three matching shelves and i was like
holy crap i need to come over here and
get some [ __ ]
i did actually
every time i go i'm like they have yoga
pants for like five dollars so i always
get a pair of yoga pants and they have
like really cheap uh lipstick and [ __ ]
like that so i'm like wow
they had a lipstick over there that's
really really nice for like a buck i'm
like well this is better than the
[ __ ] 38 lipstick i was having before
so
she said they have sausage shrimp and
crab that would actually be a good
combination i like that um
just make sure that you know your shrimp
are peeled first
when they go in there to make it easier
to eat
and uh if you're gonna put blue crab in
there
a lot of people just kind of have them
in there for flavor man because blue
crab is [ __ ] messy tearing that [ __ ]
open against a lot it's it's
it's you know
it's a lot of shell and not a lot of
meat in it yeah they're delicious though
they're delicious but most people put
them in there more for flavor than they
i mean people do eat them yeah but it's
a lot of work yeah i'm always kind of
like i feel like blue crab is one of
those foods that you're probably like
burning the same amount of calories like
getting to the meat
by the time you get in there
so
if you know if you're hurting for money
most people would rather
forgo the blue crab and throw in more
shrimp or more chicken
or more sausage
grantha's hammer said is it true that in
the south every animal part from the
rooter to the tutor is cooked and eaten
it's not true well no but i mean
somewhere i do kind of feel like most of
the [ __ ] and not commonly
but you will find people that that will
eat yeah that's most most most of that
is most of that thinking is kind of gone
yeah that's more like old people that's
like old school [ __ ]
but uh
most
most southerners will eat what's called
high on the hog if they if they can and
most of them can now which they
they're gonna eat [ __ ] good look you
can go down to sam's and get [ __ ]
pork tenderloin cheaper than you can a
bunch of shitty ass [ __ ] pork chops
per pound
you know it's not the same it's not
quite the same situation
anymore
i mean in that we we get one of those
big pork tenderloins like pretty much
every time we go to sam's it's like 15
bucks well it's yeah and it's like so
useful and you can do like tons and tons
of [ __ ] with it yeah you cut you know
you cut off that much of it throw it in
the [ __ ]
crock pot or whatever
and then you can make you taco meat out
of it you can just like well that's a
little too lean
make more like fajitas yeah want to do
taco meat out of it make carnitas help
you use pork butt
and i just bought two of them today
15 bucks each and they're huge
and i got to put them in the freezer
the lowest i'll go is a pork shoulder
and you know you can get a big old pork
shoulder for about eight nine bucks
at sabz
um it's about like pork butt it's just
not quite as lean it's it's got a lot of
you got to separate out a lot of fat but
you slow cook it you're slow cooking it
and then you're pulling it things that
don't look good you're throwing that out
and then later on you know when you're
doing if you're doing carnitas you're
gonna [ __ ] re-fry it in a pad and
it'll get all nice and crispy when
you're making
tacos or whatever it is you're doing
um
no it's
not like it was in my grandparents
generation
you know they would eat [ __ ] jowls
and [ __ ]
and uh but you they'll still eat ham
hocks smoked ham hocks especially but
that's it's because of the flavor
yeah you've never had
real red beans and rice
until you've had it made with ham hocks
and that's what it's supposed to be made
out of it's kind of like a real real
smoky bacon flavor it's beautiful well
you need a ham hock for
uh you know if you're gonna make black
eyed peas or if you're gonna make split
pea soup yeah um [ __ ] like that it's
always i mean you can put other cuts of
ham in there but it's always better to
put that yeah handhawk yeah and you're
going to want black eyed peas
um
[ __ ] um
oh [ __ ] what was that with red beans and
rice that has um
ham hocks in it sometimes it's good with
hocks in it
you just
you're cooking them and then you're
pulling pulling the hog back out you're
removing the bones from it and removing
a lot of the fat you're putting it down
on a cutting board and chopping it a lot
finer you go in and then you're going to
cook it again and then the drippings
from it and all that and then that's
going to be added into your
beads
real good that's your flavoring
that's your flavor flavor yeah
yeah janet says love ham hocks yeah
they're really good um
did you do i saw something else dude
camp guy said we keep a couple pork
tenderloins in the freezer just about
all the time they're just really i mean
they're just really good to have you can
do a lot of [ __ ] and it's like a lot of
food for not all that expensive yeah ian
england says local butcher has pork butt
for 1.99 a pound that's a good price
that is very good yeah
as far as bang for the buck pork butt is
the way to go
it's a good quality meat it's better
than shoulder
it's leaner it's only one main bone in
it it's like a blade it's like it's like
this blade shaped bone
and uh you can make any kind of pork
based food out of that you could do
chinese you could do mexican you could
do anything
you know western you're not supposed to
have that in
indian food they don't need pork and of
course nothing arabic has pork in it
and uh but
mexican food chinese food
[ __ ] american food
like pulled pork
like barbecue pulled pork
pork butt that's what you want
pork butt butt
nowhere near the butt i know i don't
know why they call it that just the way
it is
i mean because you would think that
that's yeah but it's not it's the butt
of another cut i think
there's another cut this is the butt
part of it
it's the butt of the cut yeah
that's how i'm imagining it yeah
probably right uh mary says i love white
navy beans cooked in ham hock tastes
better yeah i kind of feel like most
things any any kind of beans or anything
like that is always good with like ham
hocks in it butter beans
yeah those are good too
it's like those white it's like those
little white beans
uh they're just
more mild kind of creamy like butter
like a butter like butter yeah and i
mean like i said you can't really have
split pea soup without putting some ham
hock in there
but like just all kind of ham i was
watching one of them i was watching uh
one girl the other day on youtube making
split pea soup in her uh in her crock
pot and she put the ham hock in there
but she put like a whole big cut of ham
in there yeah too and like in the slow
cooker and then just like pulled the
bone out at the end so there was a bunch
of ham in hers and it looked really good
caught a vatsilon in there
um he's from uh tijuana
and uh he got me on to a good
mexican cook and she's uh she's on
youtube her name is the name of the
channel is cooking concluding
cooking concluding and claudia is her
name
and um
she's this little mexican girl usually
in a belly shirt
making damn mexican food and she'll
teach you how to make salsa
and it's in english so you can
understand everything she's she's doing
she does all kinds of cool [ __ ]
thank you thank you janet for this super
check i recommend that i've been
watching what she's been doing making
gorgetas and stuff and how to how to
make salsa out of tomatillos and
you know just good channel
good channel yeah thank you janet butt
of another cut another tom shirt
i told you i think i mentioned this on
wednesday but for whatever reason i
don't even know how i got off on this
kick but
i've started being fascinated by people
who have videos about like um extreme
budget challenges like i ate for a week
for ten dollars
uh from
dollar from the dollar store or from
dollar tree and like all the [ __ ] that
they make
and it's like i don't know why that
fascinates me so i like how because to
me it seems like really easy
to cook with like you know amazing
expensive ingredients it's much harder
to make something good out of like cheap
ass [ __ ] or or stuff that you you know
what i mean that's the challenge that's
what i'm saying so that's why i'm kind
of i kind of got into
uh that new gordon ramsay show next
level chef which actually i guess it's
still on because i've been watching it
on hulu but then last night i watched an
episode and then there weren't any more
so i'm assuming that it's still ongoing
and what they have on that is they have
three levels and like the top level
kitchen is like top of the line
everything then the middle one is just
kind of like your average restaurant
kitchen like a big one and then the
bottom is just like this shitty ass like
the ovens don't really work that good
and like they don't really have any
stuff and they do
you know remember that movie the
platform on netflix they obviously were
inspired from that because the top uh
people in the kitchen they get all the
best the choice of the best stuff and
then the platform lowers so
when you get to the bottom basement
kitchen uh those people have to like
just take whatever ingredients are left
over and have to make something out of
it so to me it's like way more
impressive that's why i used to like
chopped so much because they just give
you these five random ass ingredients
and if you can make something good out
of that just like on the fly then i
think you're like a way better cook than
somebody who can i mean it's easy i can
make you know good [ __ ] out of good
ingredients exactly but in the culinary
arts
the challenge is to take things
that are not expensive that are very
common
and try to elevate them into a dish that
will will sell and you can make a lot of
money because it tastes good yeah
a good example of this in the industry
would have been chicken wings
when i was a kid
a chicken wing wasn't worth anything
that was just like nothing
you could buy a [ __ ] ton of chicken
wings
for like a couple dollars there was just
nobody wanted that cut
until somebody came up with buffalo
chicken wings and all of a sudden the
the car the price
for chicken wings in the grocery store
is [ __ ] quadrupled can tupled those
things are worth a lot of money they've
now turned something that was worthless
into a delicacy yep the chicken wing
the chicken wing wasn't worth [ __ ] when
i was a little kid they'd sell that on
the damn child's menu and call it
something like prairie dogs drumsticks
or yeah mini drumsticks because
everybody's like well there's no meat on
it yeah
it's just nothing you know
baby drumstick
nobody wanted that
well
on the other hand
if
if you have expensive high quality items
they taste good naturally it's a lot
easier to deal with that component
because you're letting the component
speak for itself yeah you don't have to
do a lot to it yeah
getting in the way of a lobster
is [ __ ] over the lobster the lobster
on its own
is pretty good you don't have to do much
to it
same thing with like filet mignon okay
here's something
glenfiddich scotch whiskey what do you
do with that
ice just ice or drink it straight up
yeah
do you put coca-cola in that no you need
to get slapped if you [ __ ] put coco
you better not let anybody see you doing
it yeah look at your ass [ __ ] this tore
out the frame
putting coca-cola and [ __ ]
glad-fitted cookies
scotch
why the hell did you pay all that money
for that scotch to [ __ ] throw
[ __ ] coca-cola into it right all
right
that whiskey was meant to speak for
itself you paid all that extra money for
that flavor because it tastes that's
great
put it put [ __ ] a single malt scotch
like [ __ ]
it next to say wild turkey there's just
no comparison none
none that [ __ ] single malt scotch
will knock that [ __ ] white wild
turkey over every [ __ ] time
well turkey mad a sour mash it just just
doesn't have a refined flavor
now can you pour some coca-cola in some
[ __ ] wild turkey yeah hell yeah that
is an improvement yeah yeah as a matter
of fact i would recommend it yeah
but you you don't do that [ __ ] on a
phone and you know some people like that
i don't really like that drink but i
understand why they like it it does have
a flavor
man you do that with scotch you get
[ __ ] you can get slapped
yeah
so that's why so like i said i'm just a
lot more impressed with people that can
take something cheap or something right
and that's what because cheryl was
saying ooh dollar tree food but honestly
what the um because i've seen a couple
different there's two or three different
channels that i know of that do this and
they're trying to like help people that
are kind of in food deserts or don't
have a lot of money to spend on food and
they're trying to show
how you can buy ingredients at dollar
tree for ten dollars and make like you
know three meals a day for a whole week
that are pretty good without too much
effort so they're not buying um she's
not buying like pre-packaged stuff
because that's like kind of expensive
she usually ends up buying
stuff like she'll get like a bag of rice
a bag of beans sometimes a couple bags
of beans she'll get sometimes peanut
butter because you can make like sauces
and things like that out of it
she'll get tortillas because that's like
cheaper sometimes she'll get a thing of
bread if they have um kind of some fresh
food or sometimes they do ones at aldi
they'll usually get potatoes because you
can usually get like a five ten pound
bag of potatoes for just like a couple
of bucks and you can do a lot of [ __ ]
with that um but they usually they make
a lot of mexican food honestly um you
know because you know they'll make a
bunch of beans they make a lot of stews
a lot of stuff like that and they'll
almost always get a bag of flour because
you can make biscuits out of that you
can make pasta with that and you don't
need a lot of other things
um you know
and it's so it's like really interesting
to me how you can just take something
that
minimal and like and then they always
get eggs too because you can do a lot
with eggs obviously and they're like
really nutritious so
some of the stuff they're they're saying
is like not super healthy like the one
girl i can't remember what her name is
but she usually says
you know how many calories it averaged a
day
and it's usually between 1400 and 1600
which is you know that's pretty good um
but the other girl doesn't really do
that but she does more like in-depth
cooking stuff
but i don't know i just i find that
really interesting and like i said i
think that's why i'm kind of getting
into this next level chef thing because
it's just
when whenever the team you know because
they they're divided into three teams
and then they have to like it random
randomly assigns them to like you know
the top kitchen the middle kitchen or
the bottom kitchen so i'm always like
fascinated to see what comes out of the
bottom kitchen because
they have to make do with whatever
ingredients are left over
and they also don't have very good
equipment
down there like this stuff doesn't work
that good and they don't have like all
the tools they need and stuff so if you
can come up with something good
in that situation then obviously i think
you're like a way better cook than
somebody that you know can makes up with
good stuff pretty much most people can
do that murder hornet return says uh
jenny do you have a hard copy of your
cookbook at your house
yes i do
um where is it i think it's up there
somewhere i think it's on top of that
bookshelf over there but yeah i have one
i do have one yeah a matter of fact if
anybody ever everybody wants to buy one
and have a signed copy we do that also
yeah it'll take a while because yeah it
takes longer i'd have to order it to
here and then sign it and send it back
to you but you know
we've had we've done that though yeah
camp guy said i make my own everything
bagels get the cheap plain or onion
bagels toast and cream cheese add the
everything spice on the inside of the
bagel and the cream cheese yeah that's a
good idea and honestly i didn't even
realize until fairly recently that they
do actually make it's in the spice aisle
they make a little jar of everything
bagel
stuff so you know what i mean
because it's generally cheaper to just
get plain stuff and spice it yourself
you know cheryl's saying that how much
she's amazed how cheaper the groceries
are here that's because it's a bigger
audience canada has a population that's
spread out over a larger area so it
costs more to get anything anywhere to
anyone
yeah i guess here you just dump them off
in mass in a centralized area and
there's a lot of people that just pick
it up
competition's a lot tougher
yeah
i do really like i wonder where the
closest aldi is around here because i do
actually really like aldi the nice thing
about aldi is that all their shit's
cheap but they also have like fresh
produce whereas some of the videos that
i watched that were dollar tree even
though everything costs a buck in there
um they don't have any fresh produce
that now some of them do have like
frozen like they have frozen vegetables
and frozen fruit and stuff which is you
know that's pretty good
but
you know because i think a few of them
got like uh you know like frozen
like pepper mixes like stir fry mixes
and stuff like that so you can get that
in some dollar tree dollar trees but
some of them don't have that but aldi
has
produce and it's really really cheap so
i always kind of feel like if all these
close by that's probably like your best
bet although they don't always have the
same stuff every time because they
rotate [ __ ] out like whatever
because that's kind of their whole
business model right that they just kind
of get whatever's left over but it's
usually good [ __ ] though
there's never been a time like this in
history
where you could be pretty much anywhere
on the
anywhere in the western world and get a
get a food item from anywhere else at
any time of the year
it's never really been like that
like if i went down the store i could
probably try to find a nectarine
you could probably find one yeah of
course order one
yeah
and probably could find a com quad
i know you can find a kumquat they got
them down in publix i've seen them okay
[Laughter]
they got all kind of [ __ ] down there
could probably try to find a persimmon
and get it
yeah i think they got those down there
too yeah like you can get pretty much
anything yeah and as i said it's season
two well yeah get it straight out of
season it's just crazy to think well i
guess that's why this is why [ __ ] like
food history like fascinates me because
i think that's why i'm so fascinated
with like mid-century stuff like when
they
when they first started doing canning
and you know frozen foods and everything
and how everyone was like flipping out
about like how awesome it was
because i used i just crack up at all
those uh you know old shorts i guess
they used to show them in like homemade
classes or whatever like in the 50s
and they're all you know geared toward
the housewife of the future yeah and
she's going and like buying it
everything was in a can yeah and
everybody was just like so excited about
it which nowadays it's like gross nobody
wants to eat everything out of a can but
back then it was a big deal because
prior to that you couldn't get you know
fruits and vegetables that were out of
season you couldn't get them only if
they were canned yeah and that's the
only way he could get him yeah so uh you
know so i get that it was like a big
deal i mean people are grossed out by it
nowadays but it was a big move ahead i
can remember when i was a kid in the 70s
that certain things were only made
because it was in season yeah i remember
when strawberries came in season
strawberries came in season and man you
had strawberry shortcake strawberry pie
and strawberry ice cream you make it in
the ice cream maker because hey guess
what strawberries are available
i remember when it was peach season yeah
my grandmother would get all excited
we're gonna make some cheese ice cream
yeah it's peach time
and the rest of the recipes peach
cobbler yeah the rest of the year you
maybe they were canned peaches but they
weren't fresh peaches yeah yeah and i
mean they're not as good like out of a
can but they're i mean it's impassable
if you're just gonna use them i don't
mind some canned vegetables or fruits
depending on what it is because some of
them taste kind of funky out of a can if
you're using them in a recipe
it doesn't bother me as much honestly we
use canned like tomatoes for stuff like
in sauce and everything but we don't
really use a lot of canned vegetables
living out here it is kind of a blast
from the past
driving down the street just right out
the front here you'll see um somebody
set up a tent with a truck out there
selling yeah or uh they'll just have a
bunch of damn watermelons up on the
ground yeah selling the watermelons
yeah you should get a watermelon hell
yeah they wouldn't be as cheap as you
think it's gonna be though
i remember when that [ __ ] was like four
dollars two dollars for a big old
watermelon now they want they want money
for the [ __ ] now six bucks for a
watermelon well you know ty yeah times
are tough
[Laughter]
cheryl says canned peas or gray
yeah
i was just i guess it was that's why i
didn't really get into vegetables when i
was a kid because
you know we ate
we came from like you know my
grandmother my parents and stuff came
from like a mid-century thing and all
your vegetables were pretty much canned
i don't remember getting fresh
vegetables hardly ever i think the only
fresh vegetables we got sometimes were
celery which we usually just ate with
peanut butter on them and
sometimes
but not usually
pretty much all the vegetables were
canned and
i couldn't must have turned you off
yeah it really did because i was like
yeah it's like well yeah that was your
parents well that was my grandma my
grandparents mostly oh grandparents yeah
yeah grandparents they wouldn't buy
fresh vegetables are they just gambling
yeah and they just grew up they just so
everything tasted like the inside of a
can to me
i thought that [ __ ] was futuristic well
that's what i'm saying
but it's like for a long time i thought
i didn't like
you know peas or green beans or you know
anything really any canned mushrooms
yeah and
still canned mushrooms are gross i mean
you can still buy them nowadays
obviously
that campbell's mushroom soup was a was
was a food group remember that
man they put that [ __ ] in
everything yeah put some camel soup on
there
every like every casserole every church
lady casserole had on put that on cooked
spaghetti
and then bake it like a casserole yeah
i remember that
she was fancy
although you know what i just saw a
commercial the other day just for
yeah it was campbell's i don't think it
was cream of mushroom i think it was
cream of chicken yeah and the commercial
had them making like a quick and easy
curry
with the cream of chicken soup and some
other [ __ ] and i don't remember what it
didn't look like curry i'm going to sell
you that right now but call it that yeah
i'm just like okay close enough um not
available
this dude
who
[Music]
i can't he's from he's canadian i think
and he's uh married to an italian guy
and the italian guy is kind of like a
foodie but this guy i think his name is
brian and he's like one of these
mid-century they call them cakers that's
that's what they call it and the name of
his blog is caker cooking so he's always
making all these recipes from like all
these old like church lady
uh books and stuff like that and some of
them it's like everything has like
[ __ ] jello and hot dogs and all this
kind of stuff and it's like and his [ __ ]
is like so so funny he makes like really
cheesy like uh church lady crafts also
especially around christmas time and
it's like hysterical but some of the
stuff that he makes
like and he did he kind of like because
i know there's one that um
that does like 70s weight watchers
recipes which are a whole horror show on
their own uh so he did some of those one
of which was called fluffy mackerel
pudding i don't know why i remember that
yeah it's it's about as
nice as it sounds well the thing about
this is one thing i didn't know weight
watchers in the 1970s which my mom was
on uh you know off and on
was a lot more because nowadays weight
watchers it goes by a point system like
every they don't tell you you can't eat
this or you can't eat that um everything
has a point value assigned and depending
on how much you want to lose and blah
blah blah they give you you can eat this
many points per day and however many
points you know whatever you want to eat
you can eat whatever you want as long as
you stay under that point total but back
in the 70s it was super super strict
so
no alcohol
no
chocolate no nuts no there was like all
these huge things of food groups that
you could not eat
so
all these 70s recipe cards came out and
everything had to like have replacements
for stuff that you weren't allowed to
eat
and so you weren't allowed to have
chocolate so like for a dessert they
would have this thing that had like
gelatin and cocoa powder and it's like
and they'd call it brownie quote unquote
and it looks like
some kind of like sludge that's like at
the bottom of some sewer somewhere
and it's like i would rather just not
eat
you know what i'm saying because it's
just it's sad the [ __ ] that they made
back then it looks super sad most of
them just looked
awful and the ones that he made and i
found this update where this girl like
made all of them too
she's like most of these are just
revolting she's like some of the [ __ ]
that's kind of simple like there just
was like lettuce and cottage cheese and
pears or something she's like that's
fine but some of these other things that
were trying to replace other things that
you couldn't eat
uh she's like just why bother she's like
they're just sad and they don't taste
like anything
and it's just you know i'm sure it
helped you lose weight but
it probably made you want to kill
yourself at the same time i'd imagine
all right so today is friday and of
course uh
it's open lines friday
this is the night where we sit around
here and drink and get trashed and we
answer any questions we'll talk about
anything you guys want to talk about
just drop it in the comment section
could be any of the cases that we've
talked about or even things that we
haven't talked about
any [ __ ] suggestions for any shows
for future episodes we can go ahead and
uh talk about that tonight but in the
meantime we'll probably sit around and
talk about
food and booze
food seems to be popular tonight
of course well that's always like a fun
topic it's like fascinating these damn
fat asses
down there
also eventually i might talk about maybe
not right now but um i might talk about
some of like that boris karloff uh
documentary that i watched so we might
talk about that later because okay i
brought a frankenstein shirt on and i
got my frankenstein poster back there
um you know
oscar says sludge in the bottom of some
sewer somewhere good album title
i can't even remember
i was actually horrified when i looked
at um
the all of the restrictions that they
used to have on weight watchers like
back in the 70s they had this whole
[ __ ] list of [ __ ] you could not eat i
remember alcohol was on there because
i'm like oh no um and i remember nuts
was on there because i was like again no
i could live without
i don't know i don't know if i want to
say that i could probably live without
chocolate i could live without some of
the things on there but
you're telling me i can't eat like
almonds or cashews or something like
that [ __ ] that noise
or peanut butter
nah the hell with that i don't care how
[ __ ] fattening there well no i mean
nuts are good protein though
especially if you're like a vegetarian
that's like a good thing to eat and
honestly nuts are like a base for a lot
of like indian food and stuff yeah yeah
so
i don't i just think it's dumb any kind
of diet that tells you you can't eat
xyz i mean that's gonna fail especially
if it's like really really good food i
think that diet tells you not to eat
that that sort of see that's what i'm
saying that was weight watchers in the
70s very very restrictive oh i remember
why yeah it's because back in those days
they thought eating fat
made you fat
and that protein might make you fat
eating all those carbohydrates though
all that bread and pasta and sugar oh no
you'll lose all kinds of weight
that was the thinking of the time
i don't think you could eat sugar either
to be honest with you they didn't see
the difference between carbohydrate they
didn't they thought there was a
difference between carbohydrates and
pasta and sugar
all right they thought that you could
lose weight eating potatoes eating pasta
and bread
yeah you didn't know that
yeah well you can lose weight eating
that yeah you can't
i mean all you had to do is look at
their food pyramid
you ever seen their food pyramid yeah it
was like three quarters of [ __ ]
carbohydrates
which bread and pasta and grains and
then they had little vegetables and then
then the tippy top was meat
and that was the tippy top was sugar was
it sugar yeah no yeah it was sugar
couldn't be because carbohydrates is
sugar i know but they made a distinction
oh good i'm pretty sure i remember it i
thought well no the carbs was the
biggest thing at the bottom of the
pyramid and then i think it was um [ __ ]
now i can't remember then i thought it
was like fruits veg and then it was like
meat
fish
and then at the top was like oils and
sugars or something like that yeah
whatever it was it was crazy and it
didn't make any sense
um
and then when you when you actually did
your research and you found out why they
were recommending that is because that's
what purina and the corporations [ __ ]
had
and that's what they were recommended
because that's what they wanted to sell
did you know that yeah yeah it's like
purina and what was it what was the
other big corporation
they had a [ __ ] ton of grains and they
wanted them sold so that's what they
told the
the government to recommend didn't even
do their health it was just that's what
they had
they were just justifying what they had
yeah eat more of this eat more of this
because because this is what we have
it's good for you
mr x hercules says you guys heard of
grace o'malley no i don't think so i'll
write it down though so i can look it up
my pen go did pookie push it off the
table again okay
i have like four pens up here because
she keeps pushing him off uh cheryl asks
does jenny make tom shave his armpits
no she and my own
he was doing that long before i met him
honestly
a real anti-body hair guy yeah he's he's
not into body i'm not you know uh
[ __ ] goth dudes do not have body hair
really you do but you know [ __ ]
you're you're on porn status
you might be called to duty at any
moment
and this [ __ ] might be a public affair
you better be looking good your [ __ ]
better be waxed in the gut scene when it
rains and pours
it may not be one woman it might be two
or three of them you don't know you
don't know what could happen
you got a plan for a [ __ ] high
performance activity
especially when you're young man
that [ __ ] was wild
how often did that happen tom uh well
are you are you counting it was more
back then
[Laughter]
more back then oh my god now it's just a
habit
yeah this happened during the time we've
been together
that's true so but now it was even more
when you're in your twenties
yeah
everything was wilder it was wilder back
then yeah yeah uh pat said i thought we
were gonna talk about that movie uh gods
and monsters yeah i actually just called
it that because i was thinking about
um
i watched a documentary about boris
karloff last night and i said oh i might
get around to talking about that too i
might change the title i don't know i
never know what to call these because i
never know what we're gonna talk about
uh you know so there so there we go
uh yeah
tom chooses to shave everything he does
like i said he did he was doing that
before i met him so it's not not me not
me didn't have anything you're saying
i'm metro and [ __ ]
he's better
i'm just sexual
[Laughter]
i'm bisexual you buy me something i just
said
oh don't tell people that he's just like
you just said that in public
[ __ ] they can go ahead and simp
simple ain't gonna be easy though i'll
tell you that
send him some send him some diamonds and
he'll dress like marilyn monroe jenny's
got the [ __ ] video camera ready man
we've already discussed it and [ __ ] look
in my next video gonna come out
and me and [ __ ] full-on [ __ ]
bondage [ __ ] daddy outfit i'm gonna
be your daddy
okay
i mean everybody's daddy it's gonna be
low angle and everything
perfect lighting dropping it on the
camera
[Laughter]
sorry that's just that's really funny
the action [ __ ] shots
artistic angles
oh dear
mango says uh i saw nightmare alley last
night great movie it was a great movie i
actually want to see it again i wouldn't
mind uh buying that actually real shame
it did not do better at the box office
it is but that doesn't surprise me
uh it was sold as a horror movie with
the trailer which it is not yeah
they i don't think they really know how
to market it to be honest uh because
it's not really
the kind of movie that they make anymore
so i kind of feel like they didn't
really know what to do with it but it
was amazing i loved it cheryl trying to
get me to [ __ ] drink more than
playing dress up and [ __ ] it does
something man you got this she also said
that you're very aerodynamic exactly
high speed low drag
shirts
me and putin me and vladimir putin with
the dolphins
okay those are heading heroes
with the dolphins
dolphins can swim
he's too [ __ ] short
too short [ __ ]
all intelligent in the water with the
dolphins
singing bowie songs they'll be on the
only fans and everything me and a world
leader
[ __ ] exactly dolphins and dolphins naked
dolphins zack and zach and all these
other gay dudes would be loving it
loving it they have a full fantasy
do you have a very active fantasy
language
[Laughter]
stop getting in the way of my creativity
sorry
sorry you're shocking me out
you're shocking me out of it i'm
stifling your crease stifling my kitchen
oscar said uh tom's going to star in the
real lair of the white worm
yeah
oh my god y'all are nasty
oh them okay yeah i'm leaving it
flip it around that's yeah that's how
you do it flip it around you're gonna
flip it around flipping these [ __ ]
like pancakes
come at me like that i flip it down that
way
cheryl says uh tom swimming with
dolphins is an image i could have lived
with that
it's just eco-friendly
i just had like i had a funny i just had
a funny um
mental picture of you just kind of go
like but see i was i was picturing you
having your arms back down like that
like fins you know what i'm saying like
more than like a person yeah so you were
just kind of like [ __ ] with your little
bald head like
that would be super funny with your
little bare butt sticking them in there
that'd be me
with our shirts off
swimming with the dolphins
there's pictures of him swimming with
dolphins that gave me the idea
you didn't know that
yeah yeah
i actually always kind of wanted to do
that yeah
but you know
you can do that well i don't know if you
can do it now but i think at sea world
or something like that they used to let
you do that but it's really expensive
because i did look it up a while back
but i mean that was years ago but that
sounds like something cool to do
i went there and like fed them before
you know what i mean like uh you know
you can go up to the tank and like hang
out with them and like pet them and
stuff but i didn't actually go in the
water in there
tom's swimming with the fishies
mega says i'm not sure who should be
more afraid the dolphins are tom no i
ain't worried about yeah dolphins are a
little rapey i've heard
you know
i'm not worried about dolphins
you're not worried about dolphin dolphin
rape that's what i'm never going to have
[Laughter]
you never know never say never
that's a punch at dolphin
don't punch dolphins they don't know
dolphin don't try to rape them
yeah i didn't know i didn't know you was
alpha like
i didn't know you were talking
about right you got opposable thumbs all
right you got me
[Music]
[Laughter]
dolphins aren't straight or gay or gay
they're just um well i'll be this
they'll just be like that [ __ ] one of
them tries to [ __ ] make a move i mean
i'll call it
this is gay okay
the dolphin doesn't care they're
pansexual
i'll
[Laughter]
same thing with those bonobos
[Laughter]
[Music]
let them know man
i think bonobos are even worse man
they'll just they'll hump anything
anything or anyone
they're like not into that inner species
[ __ ] man
all that interspecies homosexuality
jumping at me with a little [ __ ]
directions and [ __ ]
zach
[Laughter]
like he's gonna try to make some money
with it
it's not gonna fly
it's not gonna fly i'm not gonna sign
the consent form
zach's gonna owe me money
that should happen
grantham's hammer said dolphins and
orcas have huge whale schlongs i'd
rather be inhaled by a vladimir
no well i've seen like uh well and i
think too it's all about them whale
slungs [ __ ]
well i've seen like some people have the
because they're arrested before okay
brought them in to send them there
turn around if i could rape it off
[Laughter]
patented yeah he's back there you
holding what's up reaching in
i'm just making sure you're not holding
anything
like he pulled that apart was that yeah
what was that his cloaca
whatever the [ __ ]
i can't
yeah
oh my god
i can't believe how we get on these
[ __ ] topics no i've seen well they
did it okay um well no i mean don't
whales have
bones in their boners i don't know i
think they do actually
because no i mean you know just from a
biological standpoint like in science
i thought that was walruses
well i think a lot of animals actually
have bones in their penises it's just uh
you know primates don't i don't think
but other animals do
so yeah you probably wouldn't want to
get raped by that they don't have they
don't have to be aroused they can just
run up and rape somebody and then run
off
yeah
[Laughter]
just like just quick run over here well
yeah that's probably exactly why that's
probably the exact same because they're
probably stealing it yeah there's no
time
it's an emergency
well one dude probably had to fight
another dude to get on it and he's
working it over another dude knocks him
off and then the other guy's standing on
the side like this oh my turn
hits it and runs
and then he's the one that actually got
her pregnancy his jeans are damn
reinforced
so all this being able to [ __ ] get it
in a [ __ ] few seconds and run it off
that that becomes
you know genetically reinforced in in
nature you know yeah yeah that's
probably what it is
[Laughter]
because like basically for some species
if you actually look at
rape is the reproductive process
you know there's there's nothing among
some not all of them a lot of them it is
but yeah no real like sensual [ __ ] going
on ducks are [ __ ] and i think even
packs of dogs do that
uh i think the one the the the the
females in heat but the dogs are
fighting each other yeah and pushing
each other off and stuff you know
the the female doesn't seem to care i've
heard that you know sometimes that
they'll they have a litter from more
than one male yeah that does happen in
the same litter
and the cat that might happen with cats
i think it does that's because this gag
activity
sec reproduction is a gag activity
fun for everybody
move away get off
oscar says the algorithm is nose diving
as we speak oh i'm sure
probably oh well it's a side track show
nobody watches this [ __ ] anyways
except for you guys
we're just doing this because uh because
it's fun
you know it's friday night uh cheryl
says new bar name tom's palace of
interspecies erotica
imagine the possibilities
right
i mean i'm pretty sure they're illegal
but uh why not it's just between animals
okay oh so no humans are allowed
sometimes yeah okay sometimes yeah just
being animals i wonder how much of that
happens like oh you saw a video of a
monkey [ __ ] a chicken
keep [ __ ] that chicken uh you [ __ ]
ran off the chicken was hit real fast
and then ran above and then the people
were laughing it was it was uh yeah
because what are you gonna do
it was in india you know they had they
had chickens and then you know they got
monkeys
just running around walking around
everywhere yeah the monkey ran down off
the power lines and [ __ ] that chicken
and ran and the dude saw it laughed they
were laughing
i think what the [ __ ]
happened the chicken didn't understand
it
but the monkey [ __ ] picked the
chicken up and just
he's looking at everybody he's going
chicken's like what i'm a sex toy now
what the [ __ ] like that and they're
[ __ ]
they're laughing and they
monkey throws the chicken down runs off
powered chicken
she was hilarious
and the chicken was like what the [ __ ]
was that and from then on that chicken
was known as fleshlight
oh i feel bad for that it may have not
been any penetration it just might have
just been all emotional you know
grabbing first yeah maybe he was just
like yeah and then she was like what the
[ __ ] was this
what is the meaning of this
i was just sitting here like pecking at
the ground yeah suddenly like some
monkeys all up in my feathers
oh my god
uh i know he was allowed
oh my god all right uh with steven
seagal here's a good question would
steven sigal be better as a walrus
[Laughter]
he should have been in tusks yeah that's
what he's asking about would have been
better as a wall right yeah
probably i don't think so now i'm gonna
say no because if he was actually a
walrus he wouldn't be able to run like a
[ __ ] all right and that's it's funny as
[ __ ]
he wouldn't be able to run around in uh
in in louisiana as a damn volunteer
policeman for a reality show and just
make a fool out of himself
um
i hate to tell you walrus he wouldn't be
able to pretend that he's every ethnic
group he's talking to that's another
thing that he does if he's talking to a
black person he becomes black
if he's talking to a white person he
becomes white because he's jewish i
guess he sees white people as others i
guess like if he's talking to a white
person he becomes more southern if he if
he he's just
he even becomes mexican he becomes
chinese
yeah i've witnessed yeah he becomes
chinese
if you start talking about martial arts
and the great of the martial arts of old
and [ __ ] he starts reverting back
through the centuries it becomes a an
ancient chinese
ancient chinese
an ancient chinese kung fu master like
the old man from grimlock yeah he
started talking about you know or
japanese or something and and here's the
thing
[Laughter]
here's the thing
dude it's a total fake
well yeah total fake
from michigan
all right he's from michigan that's no
fun though is it no
no he made all that [ __ ] he he's not a
cia operative and did was didn't teach
the seals [ __ ] the teaching cia is it's
all [ __ ] man
this is all [ __ ] i've told the story
many times having his resume
told a story to be charitable
[Laughter]
it's 1994.
i'm in the 101st airborne division i was
in the first 327th at that time that was
at that time i was in
alpha company
get sent to the mfo mission in sinai
egypt
i was out on the op 311
also known as the rock you can you can
actually google that the op311 the rock
saudi or
uh uh the rock
for the sinai peninsula and it's a
desert island it only has six dudes on
it
we used to run operations on there we
were enforcing that damn
embargo against
up against iraq at that time
this is during saddam when saddam is
still alive
we'd be up there for about a month at a
time then we have another month of
patrol and desert patrolling in the
vehicles that was real fun but up on
that desert island didn't [ __ ] drive
you crazy
i'd be up there listening to [ __ ]
cure albums and stuff and [ __ ]
looking across the [ __ ] gulf
gulf of aquaba
with our [ __ ] night vision and
looking for ships and [ __ ] [ __ ]
something looked unusual we called
[ __ ] the navy they had these oliver
perry class missile destroyers and go
down there and [ __ ]
stop the ship
we stopped the ship one time it wasn't
me that was another guy called stop the
ship and had a whole [ __ ] thing and
it turned out that that ship was trying
to sneak through the embargo so we were
like yeah got one of the whole [ __ ]
six months we were there we got one
anyway
we go back to south camp that's our main
cap and it had a bar on there we had two
bars on there really three now they come
to think of it but we only went to two
four five no the dutch bar got [ __ ]
off limits because somebody [ __ ] one
of the dutch girls and they shut the
[ __ ] down
shut that [ __ ] down they shut that [ __ ]
down because they're no [ __ ] the
dutch girls yeah because the dutch dudes
wanted her
there was only like six dutch there
they're like hey one of them was a girl
yeah a hot [ __ ] [ __ ] the dutch
girl the dutch said that's it no more
bar
it became a private bar for the dutch
only let's just take them back there's
like five dudes in there yeah
yeah
that's pretty funny yeah [ __ ]
they were jealous you know texas got
that [ __ ]
yeah
we had this do we call it texas he was
from texas and he was just well i hope
so [ __ ] that was just [ __ ]
that'd been funnier if he was from ohio
he became famous after he [ __ ] scored
that dutch girl she was cute
she was an officer and he was enlisted
all right it didn't matter though she
wasn't a lieutenant second lieutenant
[ __ ] texas was like a pfc but he got
that just through pure animal magnetism
[ __ ] looked like a damn fitness
model okay
so you know from her point of view she's
like a kid in a candy store they got
thousands of [ __ ] dudes in there none
of them had not all of them are single
which one you think she's gonna end up
with the hottest [ __ ] one out of
a thousand one out of [ __ ] two
thousand okay
this dude's like an 11.
so he he gets her
he [ __ ] hooks up with her and [ __ ]
cupped out all the the entire dutch army
or at least six seven or at least the
six years yeah
that was [ __ ] funny when that [ __ ]
happened anyway
so go to south camp [ __ ] the american
bar but we called it that
and uh they popped in the damn video
and it was a movie i had never seen
before by
a dude i had never heard i'd heard about
it but i've never seen his movie named
steven seagal
the man the man the man the mythology
the name of the movie was under siege
and man we were drunk we were loving
this [ __ ] movie they had topless
chicks [ __ ] jumping out of their
[ __ ] cakes
they had [ __ ] uh he's a cook and he's
a navy seal and he's doing all this [ __ ]
and it had [ __ ] busies in it chewing
up the [ __ ] scenery with those
massive horse teeth [ __ ] teeth
and he's in drag we were [ __ ] loving
that and then they had uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] tommy what's his name
tommy uh tommy lee tommy lee jones and
they have a knife fight and everything
and we're like man this is this is every
movie needs a knife man and a naked lady
jumping out of a cage hell yes
going forward cannons they were stealing
[ __ ] [ __ ] they were just the whole
movie was everything that you would want
out of an action movie from the 90s
especially if you're in service all
right
and they're telling me
this dude okay
was was a navy seal that he really was
he was actually in a service
navy seal
and i'm going really
you bought it yeah i bought into it
yeah and what else did he do and they're
just telling all this [ __ ] man
he's done everything he invented the
world [ __ ] yeah we're just
hearing it you know
cause i enjoyed the movie all right
and
there's a couple things about it
towards the end of the movie he took a
shirt off
and i looked at his arms and i was like
wait a minute hold on
dude's the name of seal
like yeah evidently does he have a robot
arms
arms and then my arms
[Laughter]
happen did he get injured or something
what what's the deal you know
and i'm like how old is that dude you
know and i'm trying to do the math but
you know what i suspended my disbelief
i'm like that's okay this is a great
movie it's got to be true
well that movie was such a hit
they sent us another one
i think it was just like a week later
and i think it was
out for justice
yeah i think that was the one that came
out right because i kind of feel like he
only had like a few really well actually
that wasn't the second one that we saw
the second one we saw was his first
movie
hard to kill
we saw that one and we loved that one
because because you could send a request
for things in the helicopters to come
and bring us so we were requesting
steven seagal
okay
and we saw that out we saw that out for
justice and uh hard to kill and we liked
that one too that was like [ __ ]
commando
i'm watching that and i'm going he's
kind of skinny
you know i'm thinking but i'm suspending
my disbelief
it was the third movie that they showed
us
and then you're right for justice
and he's wearing that damn
black ranger beret
and he's wearing it like a [ __ ] pogue
the way he was wearing that brig no
soldier wears a beret like that
and i'm just going no i can't and i'm
not we're trying i'm trying to
rationalize it and i'm going like this
dude sex military right and they go yeah
yeah he's they say he's a navy seal you
know
look at how he's wearing that [ __ ]
beret and we're drinking and like yeah
he's [ __ ] up why
no military man wears a braid like that
and then about a half hour later in that
movie
there's a scene where he's running
and as soon as we all see him running
the whole [ __ ] crowd of it starts
busting out laughing because that
[ __ ] was running like a [ __ ]
just chicken wings flapping and just
just the way he's why does he run like
that
i'm not like instantly saw through it
i've never seen anybody else
run like that even people that are like
out of shape and stuff any
any doesn't matter what branch of
service you're in
every branch even air force they do a
little bit of [ __ ] running in
formation during their basic everybody
learns how to run
there's no way in the world
a person who's ever had any military
service would ever run in that fashion
because you wouldn't be able to maintain
that
you know two seconds
20 minutes later you'd just be tired as
[ __ ] flapping them damn arms around
nobody wrote he's trying to like get
airborne
i'm not sure what it is that he's doing
the whole the whole thing was kind of
shattered i was like
this is [ __ ]
and then i forgot about steven seagal
after that and then years later you know
they made
these stories started to accrue
about steven seagal
and then when the internet came out that
was the end of steven seagal because you
could see all his interviews over time
on the television programs and you could
pile them up
back in the day they'd go have those
interviews and they'd never be seen
again
interview internet
youtube oh man
you could just yeah that was pretty much
all she wrote yeah because some people
like
that was saved that [ __ ] from back then
so yeah there's like put it all on one
video and then you have a voiceover just
like look at it and then you're like oh
yeah and that was that was the end of
steven's goal
honestly though how awesome would it be
if somebody wanted to get really
ambitious
and do a deep fake of the movie tusk
yeah but with steven seagal that would
be funny
oh my god okay because everybody else
does this voice i mean sure yeah oh it
went right for a second okay steven
seagal got mad at us
it's okay i think it's back um
let me get another drink murder hornet
return says i might need another one too
i'm getting kind of watery over here all
right um jenny how close are the styles
of steampunk and goth give me a
percentage on how close they are a
percentage
not terribly close there is some
crossover
and we have had like at mannequins like
some goth nights will do like a
steampunk theme you don't see it as much
anymore because i kind of feel like it's
day has passed
um i like a lot of the steampunk look
i don't know there's maybe
maybe a 10 to 20 overlap but you don't
really see it much anymore i kind of
feel like
that was maybe
10 years ago i want to say you saw like
some people with some steampunk [ __ ]
um you know in the sense that they had
like the boots with the gears on them
and like the brown
corsets and kind of uh you know aviator
goggles and
that kind of stuff you did see that but
you don't really see it all that much
anymore i think that even mannequins did
a steampunk ball
probably
six to eight months ago i want to say i
remember doing the poster for it but i
don't remember how long ago it was
and
i think only like
five or six people
wore steampunk [ __ ] you know what i mean
so i kind of feel like that's
sort of passe now and the weird thing
about it is that
during its heyday i feel like people
that were really really into steampunk
that machines make it nice well yeah
it's i hope it is because it's that's
kind of what you bought it for
but i kind of feel like they had their
own
bands
like uh you know like abney park and
stuff like that which
i don't know i didn't really i don't
know what the bands had that made them
specifically steampunk i wasn't like
really into it it was a whole subculture
but
i never knew that much about it i did
like some of the style like i do like
some of the look but you don't really
see it that often anymore you know
um
[Music]
let's see
oh jungle cruise yeah i remember seeing
the um
the trailers for that
and
i was kind of like well that looks kind
of fun i i feel like probably tom would
like it
you know but
i don't know i thought it was
maybe gonna be stupid but
uh manga said it's a fun and maybe dumb
movie well there's nothing wrong with
that
saw the cinema and then bought it on 4k
blu-ray
they're talking about uh that movie
jungle cruise hold on a second i didn't
see that one
the rock is in it right
in the rock in it
uh murder hornet says i need to come
down there and go to the goth club never
been to one
i'll bring an apocalypse baggage yeah
you'll have a good time and honestly um
other than certain events
uh
you know
like if you go to mannequins like on
friday night or sometimes saturday night
you know it's probably about
30 40 percent goth people and then the
rest of it is just like tourists that
just kind of like wander in and out
so
it's different if you go to somewhere
like more specific to the scene like you
know the castle or something but
you know or if you do if you go to like
independent bar you go to their uh
memento mori like their monthly thing
that's kind of more that's going to be
like 95 percent goth people and then
five percent people that just wandered
in and don't know the [ __ ] is going on
um but you know
it's kind of like across the board so
they i kind of feel like they started
doing i don't know if they're doing this
so much anymore because we haven't uh
been able to go to mannequins too much
because like i said we bought the house
so we don't have a lot of money
um
they started doing themes
every
friday night i guess
um so they did a steampunk ball that was
a while back they did like a
post-apocalyptic thing that was actually
kind of fun we did a little we did that
like so everybody was kind of like mad
max looking um
they did
like an alice in wonderland thing
uh they did a vampire ball
uh what else they did like a pirate
thing i think
i'm trying to remember all the different
posters i designed they did a bloodbath
that's a pretty common thing they do a
lot of the goth clubs so i kind of feel
like that old remember when we had
middle knocked yeah
they did bloodbath
at that every year i think you're
supposed to come all bloody and [ __ ]
up looking
um
trying to think of some of the other
themes they did
i can't really think of any more
but yeah you don't see much steampunk
stuff anymore do you i kind of feel like
that's kind of a bit passe
yeah jungle cruise they're talking about
the movie jungle cruise
remember i saw the trailer for it a long
time ago
and then it just got kept getting pushed
back or whatever but i guess it's out
now
um let's see mr x hercules who else said
i haven't i don't have a group
i don't know like a group of what i
don't know what you're talking about
i don't know what you're talking about
cheryl
who else thinks annie from halloween is
hot uh yeah she is pretty hot actually
oscar says here in el paso there aren't
any themed bars or even theme nights
such a bland city
yeah mannequins the inside of mannequins
looks like
i mean when he first opened it it
started it's a horror themed bar
essentially
um
although
it looks a little bit less like that now
but it still does have like a lot of
horror [ __ ] to it
but i don't have a group cheryl
but
jenny
um worked with worked with a woman named
imani
and imani was kind of like a manager
slash producer
of a lot of local black metal bands and
jenny did a lot of album oh a group on
facebook oh you do it's tom shitty tommy
movies yeah yeah shitty with with two
d's with 2d shitty
[Laughter]
but i'll finish what i was talking about
yeah i just wanted to address that jenny
was
jenny did a lot of album covers
for uh black metal bands
and they were not really bands that we
listened to they were just she just did
the covers for them but jenny probably
legendary and black metal for all we
know they're good oh you did that cover
oh you did that covers probably [ __ ]
like that i might i might be probably
so we were at
dinner with imani one time at an indian
restaurant around here and she says tom
she's from new york she goes called me
tommy because she's from new york tommy
because that's how they do up north
they actually do it down south too just
that yeah it's just
[Laughter]
tommy
what's your favorite band anyway who
should i sign
around here
and i said well i'm not in these black
metal bands no no no what band do you
like that's around here and i said
there's a florida bad here that i think
is one of the best bands in the united
states right now goth band called a
starry night
a-s-t-r-i-n-i-t-e you can look it up
so she looks into him she got him
assigned
yeah and i became friends with him
um
actually i knew them i was talking to
them before i told imani about them we
kind of came across them on youtube
randomly didn't we like when we were
looking for a new gothic yeah
on youtube to help him
promote
a night
yeah and i said why me because you come
up in all the photos
that's right that's why and it's because
in a lot of the local goth groups a lot
of facebook groups at that time
i kept popping up in the photos yeah
and really what it was is i've popped up
in the photos with beautiful women
okay that's really good
and it is true got pictures approved
it's true jenny was one of them
so uh anyway but over time
they're from miami they're not from up
here but over time um we became real
good friends with them
and that's
i believe
the best american goth bed right now the
starry night because they have and they
started off
more like dark wave
uh and
but now it's
not really dark wave but it was kind of
poppy whenever when when they first
appeared but it wasn't yeah kind of
their new stuff now is just full-on
[ __ ]
like basically the cure it's like that
kind of mixed with i don't know new
order or not new order uh no more
christian deaths honestly they've gone
like in a little bit more like their
music's gotten a lot more complex let's
get more complicated and layered
and uh yeah so that angle happened
because
he
he calls me and goes tommy who do i
sound like you have to understand
something
these dudes are all straight as [ __ ] but
if you were to talk if you were to talk
to him they they don't really they don't
they come off they like to be talked to
infin and female well michael does yeah
mike michael likes to be talked to as if
he's a fragile flower okay that's kind
of his shtick that's his stick he's i
mean
he knows that it's funny yeah he's doing
it like just to be funny you got to hold
it but it's kind of talking to him
keep him calm for the show
okay
so he
i don't want to give all his [ __ ]
artistic secrets away
but i can i read him very well and
sometimes he feels that he's not
up to hit the task that he's not
measuring up to his ideals and his
standards for himself
well all creative people
to some degree i have that too like it's
it's like an imposter syndrome
so you have to honestly have to know how
to talk to a man when he's in that can
when he's in that vulnerable state
okay
all right
and
you're you're so supportive i'm very
supportive
and and he respects my strength say my
strength
he leans against me
for help
okay and assurance okay they're his rock
yeah yeah so
he was always asking me
who
he sounds like and who i remind him of
yeah and i and i told him i said you
know you your vocal qualities really
remind me a lot in some ways of ross
williams yeah he does kind of sound like
roswell and uh next thing i know
he sounded more and more like roz
williams well he had asked me that too
and i said you guys are it's like i like
this new direction you kind of sounded
more like christian death and he didn't
know who that was that was i mean
they're like young enough to be our kids
they're very young i mean he is well he
is
brain's behind the band's guitar player
though [ __ ] he uh donald uh howard
howard you yeah come to howard the duck
donald duck
[Laughter]
oh my god howard the duck we should
review that i actually kind of have a
lot of objections
now that you've reminded me of howard
really is he knows every [ __ ] song
from every [ __ ] cool god band of all
time seriously i could talk to him like
forever because it's just kind of like
every single band like the obscure
[ __ ] band you know he just mentioned
this and that and he goes yes
and movies too like he's super into
horror movies like really obscure like
horror movies yeah
he knows all about that howard you know
fields of the nephilim you know [ __ ]
don ray's yes yes
that's exactly what you're talking about
that's that's coming next that kind of
[ __ ] you know
but um
i don't remember where i was going with
all that anyway
see what tom's like circuitous
conversations
i do that too though he does sound like
um
to me roz williams
he does a bit and now he's sounding more
and more like roswell's because
really he just needed to be shown what
what what the possibilities are he went
and looked at that and goes oh yeah okay
because there were a lot of like
so i guess him
hearing that gave him the reins
reassurance that that is a direction you
can go to that that that direction
because nothing is original everybody
has done every [ __ ] thing
i just found it fascinating that they
almost kind of landed on christian
deathy sounding and michael had not
heard christian death before because he
didn't know like who that was so i
thought that was like really interesting
howard had but yeah but uh but yeah
uh cheryl says
we're talking about uh the goth night
sounds so fun living in a small town
sucks
uh
yeah we've been there yeah so uh senor
stix says jenny would you try cyber goth
knights no i do not like the cyborgs it
gets old well and honestly
i kind of feel like the cyber thing
that was going on way back in the day
because i remember going to the castle
back in the early 2000s
and i kind of feel like that was more
the heyday of the cyber [ __ ] and like i
hated that [ __ ] then obviously you had
like cyber [ __ ] you had like gravers
yeah uh you had and i was just kind of
like why like what it was with all the
neon and the glow sticks and it's like i
don't get it i don't like it um you know
dj maniac says i always thought
steampunk was [ __ ] lame what if goths
were brown yeah
all right now there's a shout out to
that we don't we're not even affiliated
with but i think it's the other best
american band
i kept hearing this [ __ ] song being
played over and over again on a new
retro wave which is a channel that i
subscribe to and i work out some of the
music that they stream
it's called heaven's servant and i never
didn't know [ __ ] who did that we went
to the goth convention here to see a
starry night and out of the blues one of
the warm-up acts was these two skinny
guys
they're putting on a real good show i'm
enjoying it and all of a sudden they
[ __ ] bust out with that song heaven's
servant and i'm good man that's them so
after the show it says dude man what is
were you saying that song i've been
hearing that song you know what's the
name of that song he goes it's called
heaven's servant
yeah i hear it all the times where'd you
hear it now it's
it's on a channel called new retrograde
we bought a shirt from him
and um
it's a band called corey
k-o-r-i-n-e
jenny's got a shirt from them and
they're they're friends with starry
night too they they know them
they got a lot of videos out they're
little two-bit homemade videos like
something out of the 80s but they're
really really good
dark wave music
sounds like something from the 80s
corey
and i think they're from
seattle no
um
i thought like pittsburgh or something
yeah but i can't like remember
um i can't remember yeah excellent
excellent band they don't have a single
song that i think is bad everything they
do is good
and that's saying something because not
everything that starry night has done i
like
i like most of it but there's some of
the early stuff i didn't like it that
much it was good but not to my taste
um but corinne pretty much everything
that they've done i liked it
i really recommend that bad
so starry night and corey
dj maniac says cyber goth is hot garbage
too yeah i'm kind of like you know yeah
uh and then he says yeah and this is
also my experience uh the gravers
invaded in the early aughts and now i
gotta listen to vnv nation for [ __ ]
ever every time i go out yeah pretty
much tired of envy nation yeah and
honestly i didn't mind them at first
because i actually went and saw them
live one time when i was living in tampa
um but after a while yeah it's just kind
of like
yeah and i kind of feel like that was
the problem with a lot of particularly
going to goth clubs in the early 2000s i
feel like it went more in like a cyber
you know direction and so sometimes
you'd go in there and they'd play like a
couple good songs like early in the
night and then later it would be like
four or five hours it sounded like one
long song yeah vnv nation always kind of
reminded me of a kind of a
kind of i don't want to say half-assed
but kind of a little bit of a rip-off of
wolf time
it just kind of cut although wolf time
has their own thing going they're more
depeche mody yeah i kind of feel like
them and mesh and that and that was all
right i like mesh though i did too but
like i said they're very depeche mode
yeah you know so whereas vnv nation were
i guess they were kind of depeche modi
too but not i kind of feel like wolf
simon mess were made way more depeche
modi
i didn't mind some of that stuff you
talked about i don't know i didn't mind
like covenant i didn't mind something i
didn't mind i didn't mind some of the
stuff i only heard of them i had one of
their albums i think at some i had a vnv
nation album somewhere i would still
take corey over all those bands just
because it sounds like a real band and
it just sounds like guys and
and they're
singing their hearts out i just like
that band i like cory
i don't know what
dj maniac thinks of him
that new retro wave channel is actually
pretty cool it's on uh youtube i mean
because he's we usually just sometimes
if we're not like watching anything
sometimes we'll just like leave it
like and just let it play
corinne had an honesty
to it that i liked it wasn't over
complicated it was
very old school it sounded like
something that kind of
would come out of the 80s that that it's
just yeah i don't know
you just have to hear it to understand
it just sounded kind of authentic to me
yeah
pat says too many damn musical subgenres
for me to keep track of right it's like
i used to keep track but after a while
it seems like i i think at some point in
the future every single band is going to
be their own genre so there's just gonna
be
there's gonna be like 40 million
different genres i'm sure there's like
some genres now that i'm just kind of
like what even is that i mean i can i
don't know i can imagine but it's just
you know
uh let's see do people hate marilyn
manson where you live he's from there
right
um he's friends with our friend who's a
dj here yeah he grew up here they grew
up here brian warner
um
i don't know i don't really know if
anybody thinks about him that much
anymore he's not a bad guy he's just
that's just a long time ago and he
didn't hold himself together too well a
lot of drugs and alcohol
guy has a lot of problems um i mean
definitely substance abuse problems
yeah you think
i think he's younger than me
but he very well maybe you look at that
dude and he's just like looks like he's
going to die
yeah he's loaded out he blowed it out of
that yeah
i mean
we i i kind of feel like people don't
really talk about him anymore um
[Music]
people hated him you know and so we've
talked about this before like goss hated
him when he got popular
because now suddenly he did bring down
autism well yeah and like then suddenly
every goth club got invaded by all these
like
like poser ass people and like tourists
and stuff going like there might be
maryland mansion
and we're just kind of like oh god here
we go yeah you know what i mean so
so uh you know we were mad at him
because of that
uh you know but what do you what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do nothing
um let me see uh dj maniac says i might
be appearing as a guest on a horror
podcast soon they asked me
what i wanted to discuss and i said
giallo and body horror oh you're gonna
have to like tell me when that's on
because i want to like listen to that
that's like that'll be really cool i'm
doing um
[Music]
i need to do some more like jala movies
i know i just did opera and i did black
belly the tarantula like this month
february i'm going to do all like folk
horror movies like i'm going to review
those
but i am planning on doing a whole month
of giallo movies i might do like a jello
june or something like that i've i'm
going to start doing themes but we'll
see yeah tom waits was mentioned
when i was living up in boston i love
tom waits actually yeah i had a hit some
of his albums they were good
uh the problem with tom waits is that
he's obviously a fraud i mean um aren't
we all yeah
guy's 25 years old and white and he's
pretending to be a 90 year old black
blue singer you know
endearing his [ __ ] interviews and he
can't [ __ ] hold character he keeps
breaking characters it's kind of lame
but um
i was uh friends with a guy up in boston
who uh knew him
and um
didn't approve of the direction that he
went in said that he was actually a
really cool guy but
um started to
kind of act crazy on purpose until
until they got to the point where he
started to actually be crazy he said he
was difficult to be around
um he started to like buy into his own
business yeah
yeah that's always dangerous for that
moderate a lot of it might have been
substance abuse though
yeah i kind of feel like that's a it
kind of starts feeding an occupational
hazard i mean
but the guy really just wanted to be
he wanted to be [ __ ] uh
ray charles really is who he wanted to
be
but many times weirder yeah
[Laughter]
i swear to god though one of my favorite
christmas songs of all time is christmas
card from a hooker in minneapolis yeah
so just gonna say uh dj maniac said roz
williams always sounded like a spooky or
bowie to me yeah that's exactly that's
exactly what he said that's like that's
exactly what he sounds like gothic bowie
which in bowie was pretty goth to start
with i mean
if bowie hadn't been around i don't know
well i don't
i was going to say if bowie hadn't been
a thing
would we even have god or would goth
even be the same no it would be no it
wouldn't be i mean there was some other
kind of gothy things going like you had
the velvet underground and stuff like
that but i kind of feel like bowie kind
of like
solidified that [ __ ] yeah and it came it
came uh through uh bauhaus and um that
damn vampire movie that they had all of
a sudden bowie started to become very
goth friendly and
goth certain goth artists started to
sound bowy-esque
and certainly i mean bauhaus were super
into bowie yeah that was more of like
the original dark bowie type stuff
you know back when
back when peter murphy actually was
worth a [ __ ]
when he was hot as [ __ ] back in the old
days he was hot as [ __ ] back in the old
days yeah
no shame
shame what happened to him he doesn't he
doesn't look like he used to and i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] on people getting old
it's like that it happens but
he didn't uh age as well as he probably
wanted to yeah
not as well as bowie did that's for sure
told that story before
[ __ ]
me and jenny dated a girl who [ __ ]
was messing around with him and [ __ ]
that dude's [ __ ]
dude's a real [ __ ] he's um
he thinks he's moody yeah any and he
it's it's drugs
honestly i kind of think someone
understand what's real either some of
his problem is even before he because i
don't think he was a real big druggie
until later yeah um because they weren't
real big druggies i mean they they did
some drugs when they were in bauhaus but
not a lot um i kind of feel like he got
into it later because i always felt i
don't know i don't know the man but i'm
just saying the impression that i always
got from peter murphy was that he wanted
to be bowie so bad like that same
legendary status that same gravitas
and i kind of feel like he
felt like he never achieved that so he
always felt like he was lesser
and that made him like act up
because i do kind of feel like just
following the trajectory of his albums
and he put out like a got a lot of good
albums like his first one you know is
pretty good love hysteria great deep
fantastic uh cascade pretty good uh i
even really like dust although it took
me a while to warm to it because it's
very world music-y
which i wasn't expecting but then after
that he did one called
unshattered
and there was a song on there that legit
sounded like john cougar mellencamp and
you could tell that he was trying he's
like look i'm getting old now and i'm
not
mainstream famous like the way maybe
bowie was
um and he's like and i'm this is my last
grasp for like
mainstream success
because you know his biggest
album was deep
um which was a big hit like you know it
sold 300 000 copies in the us which is
not shitty like for someone as
kind of obscure as he is
it was number one it was number one on
the college charts it's a good album it
still is i mean i still listen to it but
i kind of feel like that wasn't enough
for him i don't know him like i said but
that's just like my psychological
evaluation from afar i always feel like
we just
saw him up close though yeah i mean
bowie was his hero yeah
and i get it like i get feeling like
you're inadequate because no who nobody
can be like bowie i mean bowie was like
a once in a one in a minute idolized
bowie yeah when bowie actually got him
his start in certain ways because he had
recognized but he recognized that that
was a that bauhaus was a very talented
band those dudes are [ __ ] [ __ ]
though you talk about egotistical
[ __ ] and they they they fought each
other except that one guy who gave you
an album from his that guy's real nice
the bass player
david j david j well i mean
the problem with bauhaus i mean bauhaus
you know their albums are really good
like i said daniel ash and [ __ ]
daniel ash and peter murphy are both big
egos
um and they clashed pretty [ __ ] that
having a talent yeah it's they just i
kind of feel like what happened with
that and as much as i love i liked uh
you know i love peter murphy's solo
stuff i like dolly's car i like all the
[ __ ] that he did i love loving rockets
but peter murphy and daniel ash were
really big egos
and they had a hard time working
together and i kind of feel like david j
and kevin haskins who are brothers by
the way in case you didn't know is the
bass player and the drummer they wrote
some of the songs and they were kind of
like more quiet
but they were really talented but they
didn't really get any attention because
they weren't as quote unquote pretty or
as
you know fabulous looking they just kind
of looked like regular ass cute people
but you know they didn't look as
fabulous as you know peter murphy or
daniel ash so i kind of feel like they
faded into the background a little bit
and
so i i get that they maybe was some kind
of resentment where
you know oh these two [ __ ]
you know are getting all the attention
and it was kind of that kind of thing
because honestly david jay
uh i've met him
and uh he's a really really nice dude
and honestly
his solo stuff even though it goes more
this is gonna sound bizarre but it goes
more like in a folk like alt country
kind of direction
but his solo albums are really really
good he's a really good lyricist
um some of his old solo stuff that he
did with like uh the jazz butcher and
stuff like that were really really good
he's like a really good lyricist and i
really like that he he did some like
weird like cabaret [ __ ] and all that
kind of stuff because he was into like
kurt vile and all that kind of stuff and
he did some weird [ __ ] and i'm into it
you know what i'm saying so um yeah i
just kind of feel like he doesn't really
get as much appreciation
as the other two guys got looks looks
have a lot to do with it i know and
honestly david j and kevin haskins are
like cute as [ __ ] yeah to be honest the
cabinets was the hair and the clothes
yeah i mean david jay just looked like a
regular
his with his little glasses and his suit
and everything like that he just looked
like a regular like a professor mohawk
and the right [ __ ] some fish nets and
[ __ ] he would have been it was they
didn't they didn't pick the the proper
fashion strategy
yeah they couldn't keep up with the
other two see
yeah and maybe they told them not to
yeah like don't compete with our
beautifulness yeah it might have been i
kind of feel like that's probably what
happened
i don't know i wasn't there but they
were good-looking guys they just looked
i thought they were just they just look
regular yeah they you know they didn't
really look regular so much for that day
but they weren't they weren't as [ __ ]
decked out as the other two they were
right the other two were [ __ ]
peacocking the [ __ ] out of that oh yeah
and really had i been had i been in
charge of that bad everybody would have
been [ __ ] decked out
yeah
but you're doing your [ __ ] bandwidth
[ __ ] you could have done like a duran
duran wherever where there was five guys
back in the old days right yeah you know
before they split off in 85 they were
all their own but they were all their
own chara and every every single one of
them had their own contingent of fans
right yeah you know what i mean because
they were all good-looking they all had
their own kind of thing going on and
they were very cohesive in their style
they're kind of like okay well on this
album we're doing like post-apocalyptic
or on this album we're doing like
military looking [ __ ] or whatever and
they all kind of like got the memo but
it happened if david jade [ __ ] decked
himself out got styled the other two
[ __ ] ones oh no what are you doing
they'd have been like yeah
we're the pretty ones stop it oh that
looks ridiculous on you and it didn't
[ __ ] like that they would undermine that
[ __ ] no i'm checking this on you that
sounds like terrible that sounds like
some [ __ ] that's the kind of [ __ ] that
they would like i said i don't know
that sounds like something yeah and i
kind of feel like reading between the
lines
um of a lot of interviews and stuff that
i've read with david jay and stuff like
over the years he never says it outright
because he's
classy but
i kind of feel like it was something
like that that's why they don't really
get along probably uh cheryl says the
same thing she says david j is very nice
so was kevin met them in 99. yeah i saw
david jay um at a solo show
back in 2002
i think it was
and he didn't play i think uh he might
have played one bauhaus song i think he
played spirit because that was the one
that he wrote
um but he mostly did his solo [ __ ] and i
think he was very excited that people
had come to see him and knew like all of
his
solo songs
and uh i hung around and like met him
afterwards and he's yeah he was like
super super nice getting back to all
these [ __ ] hot rock and roll
[ __ ] and goth [ __ ]
anyway let's go ahead and just we have
to give a shout out
i'm going to talk about the king
not elvis
david bowie
[ __ ]
[ __ ] those news from bauhaus and
peter murphy can talk all the [ __ ] that
they want
peter murphy
peter murphy because of his substance
abuse just he just felt
he just fell apart look
david bowie died a hot [ __ ]
dude's like seven he did and still
looked great
70 and had cancer
and the [ __ ] looked good doing
videos
okay
uh
because you know he took care of himself
and he had money and
a lot of people don't realize it but
david bowie
the richest recording artist of all
times and he didn't make the money in
music though yeah a lot of them don't
paul mccartney is the same like
real estate yeah real estate or you know
antiques or some other like kind of [ __ ]
they diversify david bowie he just knew
how to capitalize on his character
and how to make real estate investments
which they're trying to do for me right
now
they want me to take that 180 000 loan
and buy something around here
and i said the thing is is the profit
margin would only be about 300 bucks a
month and like yes but you own the
property and you get more equity i'll
get you another one
i'm trying to make trying to make thomas
trying to make me out of a [ __ ]
anyway ah
do you know what
what i was looking to i'm gonna say some
[ __ ] right how are you i don't care but
all right
it's just
what i'm going i'm going through the
paperwork
and i was looking at everything that
they filled out to [ __ ] to my
financing i got a [ __ ] we got a
beautiful loan on this [ __ ] i mean it's
cheaper here
than the old place we were at but yeah
it ended up that we're paying less
uh for the mortgage payment than we were
paying at rent or at the old place yeah
well i'm looking and the bills are
cheaper even though the house is 50
bigger yeah the house is bigger because
the house is more energy efficient i'm
going through and i'm looking at
everything and all my [ __ ]
information and data and on this day i
found out that i was latino
did you really yeah i'm latino
[Laughter]
was it that made in mexico shirt
[Laughter]
maybe it was
i found out i found out that i was
latino it's because i speak portuguese
oh because i speak portuguese i'm a
latina
huh is that all it takes is that
something yeah
yeah and that
that helped
that's pretty funny so
con
me and you are of the same breed now
we are both
now it's official it's official
i was honorary mexican but now i'm
actually legally
hispanic now
got hispanic oh my god hispanic i'm a
white hispanic
i think that's something
and i i just saw that and i went and i
looked at her and she looked at me and
she goes you speak portuguese right so
yeah yeah
well you do it's not a lie i grew up in
brazil
all right hispanic yeah
okay
uh okay uh cheryl says kevin haskins is
very pretty he is actually
he's actually super cute he um on one of
peter murphy's tours
what tour was it it was the one that
peter financed himself
i have the album from it
i can't remember what the name of that
tour was i think that uh that tour he
didn't have as many dates because he was
paying for it because he didn't have a
record company at the time uh so i
actually flew to philadelphia to see him
and kevin haskins was playing drums in
his band on that tour
just for love i think it was called just
for love that just for a love tour my
family lived in brazil 12 years
yeah i only lived there four though
yeah yeah
and like i said you had a um
tutor yeah
yeah
i grew up in brazil basically teenage
years
all my girlfriends my first girlfriends
were brazilian
they set the bar high
they set the bar high
oscar says david bowie made a deal with
the devil he must have
i mean no he made it he made a deal with
the gate with the gay uh oh [ __ ]
fight
finance ears really honestly
david bowie
was
he was
he was an artificial homosexual
and um
and he knew how to play
the gay
generations older than him
okay and i was in a bad way
they liked him
and i believe they knew that he was
heterosexual but they liked his artwork
they liked the fact that he did a lot of
gender bending stuff and they um helped
finance his career now it's not me
saying this other people that know him
that know the whole
track of his career knew that
he was the right man at the right place
at the right time selling the right
product there were people that were
willing to back him
you have it you have basically people
who invest in art you know and uh
there's a lot of very rich gay guys that
are like i love this act i wanted to go
big and
they helped him and that's really how
dudes get ahead
not just you know the same with gay
dudes you know i'm just saying that
dudes get ahead because they have people
behind them with money
that's just it's always been that way
and uh he picked the right team because
that's what that was the hole in the
market that they needed at that time and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] so big
you know
that was
all this lgbt stuff that you had the day
they had people acting like that's new
that's not new
that comes and goes through over the
[ __ ] century well i mean now it's
much harder to stand out it's just it's
it was easier back then because not
everybody was doing it yeah so
because there were a couple people doing
it that had all this money behind them
right and that made it that gave it like
a real you know a real cool factor but
also like a little bit
you know scandalous
and that was like exactly what people
were into nowadays it's not scandalous
so it's you know so no everyone's like
yawn you know and it wasn't as
scandalous even back then because not
really it was a revival of what was
happening in the 1920s
because there was a lot of that stuff in
the 1920s in europe
and even to the united states at a
certain point but only in certain cities
it was like it was
gay cabaret
act basically he was taking it main
street that's all
jeffy art says i'm convinced david bowie
bit jennifer connolly on the set of
labyrinth and that's why she's never
aged yeah because she
man she was in uh what was that movie
that you loved so much uh elita battle
angel and she looks hardly any older
than she did it's like creepy um but
yeah so i'm convinced bowie didn't die
he just descended to a higher plate of
existence
and everything yeah yeah yeah yeah that
girl was so cute
we were in high school we were thinking
how cute that girl was i love jennifer
connolly she was great
man remember the rocketeer yeah
well she was you know what's awesome
about jennifer connelly is that lately
yeah she's adorable and she still looks
fantastic
um yeah she was just in she was an elite
a battle angel i like that she's in
weird ass movies like i like that she'll
be in horror movies she was in uh dark
water like that remake of that uh hideo
nakata movie or whatever and she was in
uh
[ __ ] man what was that darren aronofsky
[ __ ] movie where she got uh
butt raped with the dildo
oh you haven't said oh you should see
that probably
[Laughter]
i they cut that scene out in some of the
uh it was it was her and another girl
and there was like a it was a
double-edged dildo i want to say i
didn't see it that was like at a party
or something like that the thing about
her is that she had a really cute face
real pale skin black hair red lips she
always was like a real life snow snow
white i always kind of feel a white look
to her and i was going to say this about
bowie too i think that if you don't get
fat
um and if you have enough money
to get plastic surgery
and stages in your life at plastic
surgery and have uh
you know have enough money to have all
your clothes fitted
to you they had trainers too that well
yeah that too but i'm just saying that
if you have all that stuff then it's
easier it's much easier to look good
people in show business who really kind
of take it seriously from the from the
especially if you're the well there's
different kinds of people in show
business but the people who made their
living being a sex symbol in show
business
from day one physicality is involved how
good they look
body
fashion everything
they have private trainers they do
cosmetic surgeries they have chefs also
they have chefs uh they take anabolic
steroids and uh hormone replacement
therapies
you can hold it together for a long long
while look at dolly parton
last time i saw dolly parton she's in
her 70s she still looked great she
looked good
she still looks pretty similar to how i
remember back in the old days she
doesn't look young
but she's still got [ __ ] little waist
and the big boobs and a [ __ ] cute
face
and
there there are people that can do it i
mean i was down at the biker bar
and i was telling you there was some
tattoo artist who was in his 30s who had
a 70 year old girlfriend and she was
cute yeah little biker girl she's about
70.
she was little and thin with big boobs
and
pretty little face and
blonde braids and
if you have the build and you spend the
money you do the right thing and you
wear the right clothes and
yeah
70 is an old lady that's an old lady but
see but she she was still attractive
she's like yeah i'd hit that yeah that'd
be fun you know what i mean well when i
say you know and i cuz i kind of feel
like some people like get uh a little
bit butt hurt but not anybody here but
some people have like when i you know
[ __ ] on old people yeah but i'm not
talking about age i'm talking about
attitude yeah
um i'm an old lady yeah but i like to
think you're not yeah
i'm not that old i'm 50. but um i don't
really like to
you know if you're not if you don't act
like an old person or you don't really
like look like it you can even kind of
look like an old person but if you still
have like some fashion and some cool
[ __ ] going on then you don't come across
as an old person to me because honestly
i know some people
who like that i've met in the course of
my professional life and stuff that were
younger than me that i still thought of
as old people yeah even though they were
younger than i was just because of the
way they looked or the way they carried
themselves or their attitudes or
something like that they seemed like an
old person even though they were younger
than me so when i say old people i don't
necessarily mean old in age i mean there
are guys at the club
that 10 years ago looked like old men
and then
you know exactly what i'm talking about
yeah and they look even older that dude
looks even older now
you put in me and him
side by side
you'd think he was in his 60s no that
dude's way younger than me
a lot younger than me
but it doesn't look like it
you know what i'm talking about oh
armpit liquor
or pit liquor
yeah
oscar asked me if i ever listened to
suede
they were pretty goth in the early 90s i
remember liking some of their songs i
don't know if i'd call them a goth band
i think in the u.s they were usually
just called they were just lumped in
with like the brit pop
bands like pulp and [ __ ] like that which
uh i kind of like that you know i don't
think i ever bought any of their albums
but i did actually like like some of
their songs and i have some of their
songs on my phone
so you know uh so there was that
uh yeah oracle says betty white was
young until the day she died that's yeah
that's
pretty much that's one of the people i
was thinking of because even though she
lived i mean she was gonna be a hundred
and she died like a little bit before
she turned a hundred but just her
attitude the way she carried herself she
seemed much younger
than so she you know yeah she's an old
lady but she didn't come across as an
old lady to me yeah you know what i mean
one i was just talking about was about
70 and uh she looked great and uh was in
her little biker outfit little biker
clothes and little hat and her little
braids and stuff and
with a dude who was in his late 30s
and
he's eating it up and it kind of was
like yeah the biker [ __ ] community
calls me the old lady your mama
if if a mama is a is a biker [ __ ] she's
kind of like available to everybody
that's nobody that's nobody's girlfriend
somebody's girlfriend is your old is
your old lady or your wife it's your old
age so i said that's your old lady and
he's like yeah that's my old lady all
right
and she got kind of uncomfortable and i
was like we don't know what i'm trying
to say i said you know what i'm talking
about
i don't know if she you're married don't
call her your wife you know that she's
definitely not not
not a mama and he's like no i'm just
joking with you and i said she's cute
and she kind of relaxed after they says
you look cute how old are you
you know
it's but you know she was a little i
think a little uncomfortable
about being that age you know because
everybody was younger than her i get
that but
she was cute
she was gay if you saw her you would
think oh she's she's like five feet tall
probably about 80 something pounds
oh maybe 90 pounds i'll put her in my
pocket yeah
braids you know blonde braids and a
little becker hat on and [ __ ] little
biker outfit
and big old implants and uh
like a little
skinny kind of country
she looked like a little dolly parton
kind of
like that she was she was hot yeah and
um
i was like dude she looks good man she
goes yeah she looks good you know he's
like yeah you know if i could you do
good do that because you know dude's
probably like 35.
that's cool though yeah
i well i always like it when dude
because i kind of feel like it's such a
stereotype that dudes are like oh they
all want like [ __ ] 18 year olds no he
was scored and she's like 70. she looked
like a
she looked like a fetish model right you
know i mean she looked like she'd be
like a 70 year old [ __ ] porn star
with a bunch of plastic surgery
but
he was happy to have her she looked good
you know it's like yeah
hell yeah i understand it i understand
it completely we'll see there you go and
she had a good personality she was funny
you'd liked her she was cool i'll have
to go down there once you need to go
down and back i still haven't gone down
yeah
i just i never get around to it they
weren't from here though they came up
here for an event oh okay and they
stopped off on it that was during bike
week wow all right see we're from here
cheryl says uh jenny looks amazing thank
you i look older and i'm 10 years
younger
oh i'm sure you don't well you know we
haven't seen you so we've been judged of
that yeah i'm not gonna say anything
yeah
victor says jenny what book should i
read for february oh man that's like too
much pressure i don't want to
because i don't want to recommend
something and then you read it and
you're like what the [ __ ] i didn't like
that book at all
i will say what was one that i read like
recently that i was really into god damn
it
um
i don't know i'll think about it and
i'll get back to you i think that i
reviewed
one i really liked the the recent one
that i reviewed that was called jar of
hearts it's kind of like more a thriller
than horror but i was kind of into that
um
and i don't know if you saw my last
review like i put up a review of stolen
tongues by felix blackwell and i feel
like everybody was talking about that
book
and
i didn't love it it was okay
but
you could totally tell that it started
out as a series of reddit posts
let's put it like that because that's
well you know every now and then like
somebody will post something like no
sleep or you know like the creepypasta
sites
and it'll get enough traction enough
attention that people like oh my god you
should probably publish this as a book
and that's what happened
um
it's not bad it was just like the middle
part of it was a little uh saggy and a
little repetitive but a lot of people
seem to be into it and that's the reason
i ended up like reading it because
everybody was talking about this [ __ ]
even though it came out like a few years
ago but for whatever reason
everybody was all into it now but um
the one i'm reading now
let's see i put up a jack ketchum one
i did a jack ketchum one that's going up
monday
and then i did i finally did a darcy
coats one like a haunted house one that
was actually pretty good and the one i'm
reading now is called
six rooms by a gemma amore
and this it's i'm about three quarters
of the way through it's it's okay it's
pretty good but
i don't know i have a bunch lined up so
i'll try to think of something
oh you know oh i got an idea you know
what you should read read some
stephen
dobbins
if you're already
i had never heard of him i just came
across some of his books like when i was
at barnes noble years ago and they were
selling off some hardbacks really cheap
i bought
one called the church of dead girls
and which is awesome and then there was
another one called the boy in the water
but he's written like i have both of
those like in hardback and they're both
really really good the church of dead
girls is like really really good
but
i don't
but he's written a lot of books but
those are the only two that i've read
but i really really like them and
honestly i'm gonna reread them soon
so i can do reviews on them
but
oscar says lol tom made that old lady at
the bar self-conscious
yeah yeah because he probably said all
kind of inappropriate things well not
inappropriate but just like
um no i was talking to her boyfriend
said so who's this it's your old lady
and he goes yeah that's my old lady and
she got something that was but i don't
mean that
you know yeah that might be not a good
term to use
well that's the bike return i know it is
but
i said well you know she's like are you
calling me old [ __ ] you
he's just having a joke that's well
she's cute and she's like and then she
like you know i was like yeah she is and
she goes yeah she's [ __ ] really cute
how old are you she's like i think she
said she was
70. i think that's what she said it's a
herald and mod situation yeah and i said
you look great well not that extreme
because he's like and he's like yeah she
does look good did you you know and i
was like yeah she's cute i've never seen
when that that age it looks that cute
i've never seen one that old that was
that yeah
just being truthful because i've never
seen that world look that cute she was
cute
it's good that you appreciate a broad
range of yeah of ladies she was
attractive
during uh of all different ages well
it's you know
it's not random he's like yeah she's
she's good-looking and she's yeah she is
yeah because she was like 35 yeah yeah
yeah she looked great
mary says
he knew exactly what i was talking about
you know exactly what i was talking
about mary says tom looked 40 at 18.
the cheryl says
that's not nice
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] lying mary says at
18 i looked 16.
you did actually i've seen pictures i
didn't know you then but yeah i've seen
pictures yeah he looked like a he looked
like a baby rick springfield yeah back
then at 24 i looked eight he had like
feathered
yeah feathered blood at 24 i looked 18.
yeah
at 40 i looked 30.
yeah you did look you you looked like
really young yeah uh nobody knew how old
i was when she met me people didn't know
how old i was no
uh let's see
mary said in high school some dudes
looked old and got the booze no question
yeah
i do kind of feel like
there there were those types of people
that looked
old already like in high school or at
least looked old enough to buy booze
though like they didn't get questioned
like they didn't get carded
i didn't have that i was i always had
baby face
so i got carded at 38.
yeah i mean i got carded up until i was
in my late 30s yeah my mom did as well
yes and i looked real young when i met
her
yeah i met you when i was 38 yeah 38.
she looked like she's about 25. and i
was still getting carded then yeah my
mom did as well my mom got carded until
she was in her late 30s or early 40s
same kind of thing we just have like
baby faces
and we're not real we're not wrinkly
too yeah i think that helped because my
mom is still not wrinkling her mom
look like um
oh what's her name piazza dora
my mom does look a lot like peanuts she
used to get that a lot actually
more than one i remember one person more
than one person saying that she looked
like pizza she did look like people look
just like piana's pizza door when she
was younger yeah
let's see
back in the day
was it ever okay to smoke cigarettes in
movie theaters no
i don't know i thought you could
couldn't even smoke in brazil
you could smoke cigarettes and movie
thing you could smoke cigarettes on
planes
in the 70s not in our times
well i mean
not in our lifetime not when we were
going i don't remember it
no i don't think i don't remember it my
whole life i don't remember that i think
i've seen it in movies
like
people in movie theaters or on airplanes
or something like that smoking but i
think that by the time i was old enough
to go to movie theaters by myself i
think that that had been curtailed i
used to smoke in in airplanes yeah
in airplanes yeah
which is weird now to think about yeah
that you're like in this little smoking
tube with all grocery stores walking
around a grocery store smoking i
remember that yeah
there were ash trays everywhere put ash
trees that's [ __ ] crazy yeah
it's not crazy it's just a different
time
yeah i mean
i i always smoke i still like to smoke
but i don't smoke i haven't smoked in
five years now if i could feel real
great it's better not to smoke but you
know i started smoking when i was 16. so
camp guy said i smoked cigarettes in an
airplane in the late 70s yeah i'm pretty
sure that it was like maybe the 80s that
it stopped although i didn't fly in an
airplane until the 90s so i'm not
entirely
i don't think i flew in an airplane
until the early 90s
because you know when i was a kid we
were too broke to fly anywhere
i remember people smoked every i
remember people smoking in the mall
i remember people smoking in restaurants
because my dad used to always smoked
he might still i'm actually not sure
because i haven't seen him in a while it
may depend on scene i remember during
werewolf in london it may have been
depend depending on what state you were
in
you see
most of the time
that's the time i was uh during the area
you're talking about i would have been
in california and i'm not i'm not sure
it would have been legal in california
in the early 80s
when i remember being in theaters in
late 70s i just don't remember people
smoking although when i did
go to theaters that time a lot of times
my babysitter is taking me
and we would go during the matinee
so it was daytime it was mostly younger
people because the working people were
you know working
adults were working so yeah and it was
during the
weekday so i don't know
and then um
then i was in brazil
and i don't think you could smoke in a
theater in brazil
because of fire hazard
and then i would kind of come back here
during the united states during that
time and uh i was going to mississippi
and the theater's there and i don't
remember them smoking in there either
i just i just think that
the time in which i lived when i was
young when that was going on where i was
what state i was moving around i don't
think i ever
got into the [ __ ] smoking in the
theater action
i don't remember it
i'll tell you this though
70s and early 80s mississippi
day drinking you could drink during the
day
no matter where you were
you could drink and drive
that wasn't the problem
and you could drink underage that wasn't
the problem
it was almost kind of like you were
supposed to be drinking
what are you talking about
drinking underage in mississippi i don't
think there was an underage when i was a
little kid they did not care about
alcohol
you couldn't buy it but you could drink
it
yeah
what the [ __ ]
damn it's all this [ __ ]
so i remember
going over to friends house
and they would grab a watermelon out of
the backyard because they were growing
watermelons in the backyard and they'd
take a knife and they'd cut a hole in it
and then
vodka and they'd pour they poured
tequila or vodka into the watermelon i
remember those days and then they'd plug
it back
shake it yep and roll it
and try to get that
booze to seep into the watermelon
and then you'd cut slices off of it real
carefully and lift them up out of the
top remember that and you'd had it in a
trough so you could catch it all all the
and and between four four or five people
you would eat that whole watermelon and
end up drinking all the juice out of
that watermelon
and there was a whole fifth of either
tequila yep
or vodka in that
and i was like
11
maybe 12.
and
the dude in charge of that whole thing
at that time that was my my cousin's
cousin
because everybody was some kind of
cousin
even if they were my cousin david's
cousin
okay that did that
and i think biologically he might have
been about 18 or 19 okay
psychologically he was probably about 12
himself because the [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] because this is the way it was
there wasn't a big difference between an
18 and 18 year old and a 12 year old in
those days in that area yeah it really
wasn't everyone was all low information
anyway there was no internet
and we were just it was just about
having fun
and he had his girlfriend over who was
probably about 16.
and
you're like 12
and you know and and she's fat and she
brings her fat friend over and her fat
friend is probably about 16 or 15
and they're all trying to get it on with
each other and and you being 12 or 13
they're trying to get it on with you too
because that's why you've got to get
some too you know
there isn't a
idea of about underage or any of that
it's just
mississippi was tribal and it was third
world
but we didn't look at it that way it was
just normal they just all piled on one
another and just started rubbing their
genitals yeah
and then he never knew and they'd be
playing a foreigner on the radio you
know remember that [ __ ]
foreign wait is that foreigner no i
don't think it is
and then then they would have [ __ ] song
did they do
what was that song i can't remember now
one in a million girl one and a million
girl [ __ ] wow that's the tubes
and um this is happening she tolerates
it in the back of a [ __ ] old
mississippi house and they got corn
growing out there and everything you
know you guys think i'm bullshitting
in the early 80s
about half of mississippi was still in
the 1930s
in the 80s
why pay for food when you could grow it
it was they were just
that was the thing about that time
looking back on it why buy meat when you
can just run over a possum with your car
doesn't [ __ ] eat that
[Laughter]
it was uh i'm exaggerating they lived
off the grid back then they had power
but they were kind of like proto off the
grid
proto survivalist did they have an
outhouse no they had plumbing okay
that's good they had plumbing
and
uh but uh
if they lost plumbing they'd just build
a house they wouldn't give a [ __ ]
it's like i'll poop in a hole i don't
care
they were like oh that's like we had
when we were kids yeah they wouldn't
give a [ __ ] whatever
uh they were um
they were poverty proof
they could be poor as [ __ ] they'd still
be eating good
they could can things
put things in mason jars they could grow
things and uh
they were [ __ ] drunk a lot
they got a lot of alcohol they could
make alcohol they could [ __ ] distill
it they had good skills
real good skills yeah that seems to be
that seems to be like a good skill to
have oh yeah
yeah
they could distill alcohol i just would
build a house i can grow food and make
alcohol yeah sugar potatoes or rice or
apple peels and all kinds of stuff and
they put it in there and they can make
alcohol out of that
and it was free
well other than like the labor and time
and stuff involved but still sure had
time because yeah a lot of people didn't
have jobs yeah yeah oscar says jenny do
you also appreciate a broad range of
broads
i do
i i appreciate a broad range of humans
of all shapes and sizes
honestly if you have a thing going on
and you're working that thing that you
have yeah um
i'm i'm about it you know what i mean i
don't
you know and i've told you this before i
don't really i don't have a type per se
i know some people do and i'm not
[ __ ] on you if you do but i don't
really have a type i'm just kind of like
let me like get to know you and let me
see if i
if i vibe with you or not if i vibe with
you or not then yeah it isn't at all
uh mango says if you watch nightmare
alley there's a lot of smoking in that
movie yeah because that took place in
what like the 1930s uh kailyn higgins
says do restaurants still have smoking
non-smoking sections no i'll go pretty
sure not i'll go um even most i mean it
varies from state to state but i don't
really think they have that anymore
uh some places will still let you smoke
on the patio yeah but not everywhere so
you have to check um honestly even a lot
of bars don't let you smoke although i
will say that eye bar in downtown
orlando will match you they will let you
smoke in the front
you can't smoke in the back where the
dance floor is but you can smoke in the
front bar
so this biker bar here does not allow
you to smoke in there you got to go on
the side of the patio yeah and honestly
that's why i'm
i mean used to be eye bar was one of the
last holdouts um they used to let you
because in the time when we were smoking
they let you smoke in there they didn't
really care even when most places were
not letting you
but recently like the last two years
they made it well now you can only smoke
in the front bar but you can still smoke
in there we quit smoking because of
vaping
yeah vaping got the day i started vaping
i stopped smoking yep and then a couple
years later i just stopped vaping didn't
need it
i like to vape though even though i
cough now
i i just
got sick of carrying that damn mod
around but i love to vape i love the
smoke still do
just
don't every now and then when i'm at the
bar not so much recently but every now
and then when i'm at the bar when i'm
really drunk
and if somebody offers me a cigarette
um then i'll take it vaping is a lot
safer than cigarettes yeah um i wouldn't
smoke cigarettes now just because of
cancer risk and longevity and what that
did to my dad what that did to my
grandmother she was a [ __ ] terrible
smoker
that's a bad bad one
yeah my grandfather also had emphysema
from vaping is a lot better and you can
add nicotine nicotine itself is not
really a health risk
what's a risk is burning things and
inhaling it you're not supposed to do
that with vaping you're inhaling water
vapor and it's
nowhere near the risk nowhere near yeah
i mean there's a risk but it's
negligible i mean compared to right
smoking
so
and that got me off smoking
i was actually amazed because i mean i
remember you saying i would smoke like a
chimney i [ __ ] loved it never wanted
to stop yeah and you're like i never
want to stop i love smoking i love
smoking but the day that you started
vaping
you were like okay i don't need
cigarettes anymore and that actually
like really surprised me yeah i was like
i was like this is good enough i was
like because honestly like we both
started vaping around the same time but
it took me a little bit longer even
though i hadn't been smoking as long as
you i honestly didn't start smoking
until i was in my late twenties yeah i
didn't start as a teenager i just never
got around to i got my mods around here
i might actually [ __ ] fire that [ __ ]
up
make some coils and [ __ ] vape again
but i just never had i can't vape
anymore never had the [ __ ] wheel to
do it because i feel like i love the
vape though i mean it had a moment like
we got really into it i remember you
like you know you talking about mods and
everybody was really into it you're
we're making our own uh vape juice and
all this other stuff liquid and
everything yeah we were making all that
kind of stuff and then i kind of feel
like you don't really see anybody doing
it anymore i kind of feel like it was
the truth so they stopped vaping because
they stopped smoking yeah
i mean it was good for that because it
really did get everybody off because i
don't really see we have
i can think of maybe
two of our friends that still smoke
yeah two
smoke or vape
smoke okay the guys that still vape
never smoked
yeah they never did smoke they just
vaped yeah they're still vaping
but they do zero nicotine just flavor
well that's kind of what we did we
started out with higher nicotine and
then just like less and less and less
and then it was just like no nicotine in
there eventually you got like why am i
doing this yeah it's like this isn't
just another thing to carry around right
i'm carrying this [ __ ] around and i
don't really need it well i got to a
point where i used to have my you know
the vape rig in my office and like you
know i used to kind of smoke it while i
was working or whatever and then i
realized that i had gone like an entire
week without picking it up
without really like needing to so
you know like i said every now and then
when i'm really really drunk not so much
lately probably this is going back maybe
like six months or a year sometimes when
i'm out at the bar and i'm kind of drunk
and somebody says hey you want a
cigarette like if especially like if
somebody like if jen has clothes or
something like that i'll be like oh okay
i'll have one but i don't know most of
the time i don't think about it and then
because i always think to myself oh
tomorrow like the inside of my mouth is
gonna like taste like garbage so
so i don't usually but if i'm super
[ __ ] up i probably will but another
drink yeah all right i'll make you one
victor says the interweb says movie
theaters had smoking sections up until
the 70s that's kind of what i thought
yeah i mean but that's kind of what i
thought i do remember people still
smoking yeah in the 70s i don't remember
that that well because i was a kid
and you know we just went to like kids
movies so people weren't really smoking
in that but
um let's see
oh i got like way behind
doo doo
vaping looks hella bad for you because
of how much smoke it allows you blow out
although honestly this it's not really
smoke it's just water vapor so
like i said it's probably not
completely harmless but compared to
smoking
it's probably nothing and honestly like
most of the flavors that we had were
just were
you know it was just nice smelling water
vapor it just smelled like strawberries
and some [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean
so
i like the videos like what you can make
with nutella
i want you to like watch that other
probably just make me hungry to be
honest
yeah i remember people smoking in the
intermission at the theater it's weird
because
i can think
i can think back like 10 years ago a lot
of people smoked like we would go to
venue 13 for example
like going back
you know six seven eight nine years when
we were first going out that's great as
you take ice it makes more ice
that's how it works what a nice little
machine
it's a nice machine
he's very considerate uh yeah we just we
just bought a new little ice making
machine so because we're too lazy to go
down and get ice out of the refrigerator
from downstairs
so we got a little tabletop like he
bought a little tabletop ice machine and
a little bitty mini fridge so we could
keep the juice and stuff in there too so
we don't have to walk all the way
downstairs because we're lazy like i
said
uh but you know it's nice to have like a
self-contained kind of [ __ ] going on up
here i'm into it
so uh yeah what the [ __ ] was i talking
about oh so
even going back
to when me and tom were first going out
like you know nine
eight nine ten years ago when we went to
venue 13 i kind of feel like there was a
lot of people that still smoked because
you couldn't smoke in the club but they
had like a big huge like back patio
and that was kind of like the place to
be man like you would go you'd go dance
to a couple songs have a couple drinks
and then everybody would go out to the
patio and go out there to smoke
and honestly
i'm thinking back to like the last few
years of going to memento mori and going
to mannequins and stuff like that and
you really don't
see it much anymore i mean i'm thinking
about going to mannequins you can't
smoke in mannequins you have to go
outside
um and it's downtown sanford so there's
like a bunch of other businesses around
but most of them are closed although
like the one across the street is open
because it's still like a
you know like a restaurant bar type
thing
and so people will go and there's little
seats out there so you can go out there
on the front sidewalk and smoke but i
kind of feel like not a lot of people do
it's
a handful if that
and honestly of all our friends i can
only think of
i can only think of two people that
still smoke
um which is crazy
so
and honestly i'm actually surprised that
eyebar which like i said it's called a
barbarella now which is what used to be
called it used to be called barbarella
then they changed it to ibar and then
recently they changed it back to
barbarella
um
they still let you smoke actually in the
front bar but
most places
inside they do not let you smoke at all
um
let me see is inflation all over gas is
like 335 here regular
honestly um last time i got gas i don't
drive my car all that much anymore
because
i work at home and you know we've been
broke so we haven't really been going
anywhere i drove my car to the dollar
general today and then i was like oh i
need gas i only it's like 19 miles to
empty but i didn't feel like going down
to the gas station so i didn't because
the dollar general was like literally
right there i probably could have walked
to it but
um you know but i didn't
so
uh i think ours is three last time i
looked it's it was three something three
fourteen three fifteen something like
that last time i got gas
uh mr x hercules says my guess is 420
yeah i mean
it's expensive but
we don't um i don't use my car all that
much anymore
uh we get a memento mori once a month
sometimes we go to mannequins which
isn't that far
uh other than that we don't really go
anyplace so oh you've got pookie yeah i
got a pokey pant why'd you you're just
like oh my god
hey
look at the people pokey
say hi to the people she's like i don't
i don't know if i wanted to
yeah she's weird like that that's why i
always close the doors because it's like
you're doing it if you leave the door
open she comes in and like stares at you
while you're peeing yeah she's like
we're gonna have a moment me and you i'm
gonna watch it and i'm like quit being
weird why are you being weird i'm
closing the door
she had to go in there and witness it
why are you on a witness she's like is
that your litter box i also use a litter
box yeah i do that too
i do that too
yeah do you do that
well i mean to be fair
pookie is she watches us do everything
everything if i go somewhere she [ __ ]
follows me what do you start working
with something and she's healing
she's
she watched me run a screwdriver and fix
like
i was putting into the the bumpers the
door bumpers when you open the door you
got a little bumper there on the spring
i i replaced a bunch of those
she went every to every [ __ ] door
that i replaced
and watch him replace the damn bumper
spring
and she looked at me like okay
let's go to another one she's like she's
watching and she's looking at me when
i'm done she's like okay
she is the most involved kitty that i've
ever whatever it is you're doing it
doesn't matter how boring it is like
seriously i get up in the morning i come
to my office i'm making a cup of coffee
yeah and she jumps up on the thing
and like sticks her face like hey what
are you doing you making coffee and then
she sticks her face in the cup is that
something for pookie no that's not for
that's not for pookie that smells weird
and then it's like
i don't know what it is she's just she's
fascinated with everything that we're
doing that's okay though yeah is that
sink on over there because she just
jumped up there to get water i think i
left it on but i can't i usually leave
that sink dripping a little bit because
she it's not a little bit
okay
i usually leave it dripping because she
likes to she has a water fountain out in
the hall
but for whatever reason she likes to
drink out of that sink in particular
so i i know it's terrible for the water
bill but i usually
usually leave it dripping just a tiny
bit because she likes to jump up there
and drink out of it she's so weird
um
yeah tammy says my female cat sits on
the bathroom sink so she can watch you
go
i kind of feel like because i've seen
like other people
post pictures of themselves like sitting
on the toilet and like the cat like
sitting in their underwear or their
pants like at the bottom
so i guess it's a thing like cats are
fascinated with
watching their kids it's a function that
they do and they are seeing and so
they're like related oh yeah yeah i do
that too but like i said see that's why
i have to like close the door i'm like i
don't want pookie watching me while i
pee that's like weird
and i even tell her i'm like i'm closing
the door don't be weird
that's how i interpret it i guess i mean
they're like oh you did i do that too
we're the same that's what they're doing
well i mean i'm gonna help you through
this this is the case
you walked me through this spooky okay
because i had never done this before you
know what i mean that that's that's
that's the that's the mentality you
should have seen earlier
uh while you were gone i said well i
stripped all the bed and i took all the
uh you know went to wash the sheets and
i washed the comforter and i watched all
the uh you know what do you call them
the pillowcases and everything and every
time you make the bed or strip the bed
to wash the sheets or whatever pookie
has to help
and she's not really helping i'm i don't
want to say that too loud because i
don't want to hear her feelings but
she's really not helping she just like
jumps up there and like grabs at the
[ __ ] and then just like if you're trying
to like pull it because i'm trying to
get it off the bed and she's like
no no and like so i had to pull it off
and like i'm pulling she's like put it
over and she's like nope i'm just
sitting here in the middle of the bed
with this [ __ ] and she wouldn't let
me take the [ __ ] sheet off i'm like
this really has to go in the laundry i
don't really know why you're not
yeah but i tell her i'm just like you're
such a good helper she's such a good
helper
even though she's totally not helping
so do you guys have any ideas for any
future shows you want us to do
i wrote down a couple somebody said the
el paso walmart massacre which i think
somebody asked about before any
questions on any paranormal or any uh i
don't know [ __ ]
current events i know they're looking
for a fifth [ __ ] force right now
in terms of they're looking for a fifth
force in nature they think they might
have something there it's tom forest
yeah it's tom forest
what are you doing mr x hercules says
i'm 32. i'm attracted to women in 35 to
50s
yeah fair yeah you know um
because of the [ __ ] wide world of
[ __ ] porn it's kind of open to the
eyes
of porn to a lot of these younger guys
that howard
that [ __ ] um
attraction
attraction or attractive females don't
end at [ __ ] 25
you know they've got some women that
[ __ ]
50 something just smoking hot
now it's not the same figure it's not
the same proportions
uh but no man
they got some [ __ ] women out there
that are
old they're older than me they look
great i mean
a good example is [ __ ] i you know i
really i'm a real fan of ryan connor
ryan connor is my age and that woman
still looks [ __ ] great
is she natural no she's not she got a
big old booty big old booty big old legs
[ __ ] cute little feet
um
big boobs and [ __ ] yeah little feet i
thought you didn't like feet she got
little feet because her [ __ ] legs are
so big
you know what i'm talking about i think
that's why my feet are small well my
feet are like small too but i think my
feet look smaller people legs because i
have big big boobs and [ __ ] yeah you
know
and no okay
um
you can't look like that at that age
male or female you know what i mean
and of course the styles can be
different between the males and the
females
you can't look like that normally i mean
she's got implants
she does hormone replacement therapy
she's done [ __ ] hgh i can tell by
some of the procedures that she's done
on her face which i wouldn't have done
hch but hormone therapies and [ __ ]
anabolic steroids
uh kind of kept her in that shape um she
looks great you know
um
had she not been doing what she was
doing that girl that women would have
been fat
there are a couple different body types
you have to understand i come from a
an agricultural background you know not
only a soldier but
you know my family my mother and
everything even back before i was born
she was a horse trainer and i come from
a horse farming background
and a cooking background when i'm not
doing
military type contracts and
i look at human beings like domesticated
selectively branded animals
uh you're an animal because i'm an
animal and all animals are animals uh
themselves are the same things we were
doing to [ __ ] uh english equestrian
horses and racehorses you know with [ __ ]
like equipos and
all these little things that we give
them to [ __ ] make them heal up faster
and be bigger and [ __ ] bigger
stronger horse you know
and um
beauty and perfor and excellence does
not something that happens
with you just sitting on your ass
stuffing your [ __ ] face
and being [ __ ] lazy
gotta work for it
gotta work at it
beauty is never natural everything is
[ __ ] unnatural
being strong is unnatural look at pookie
get get
she went into her little pile of toys
that uh that auntie elsa sent me yeah
and she just picks one out and then she
picks it up and then she rolls over on
her back with it
being unhealthy isn't that being being
healthy is unnatural
uh eating right is unnatural wiping your
ass is unnatural brushing your teeth is
unnatural everything amounts to being
unnatural and everything amounts to be
life extension
so you have to do something to get
rewards
look at pokey laying on your back look
at that
this is what she does if she does
something bad that she knows is bad
because she's smart she knows when she's
not supposed to be doing something
like she's over there tearing up my
books like she takes all the books like
on the lower level she's torn up all the
spines and then i look at them like
spooky what are you doing and then like
she looks at me and then she rolls over
on her back and puts her little like
paws up like that and then looks at me
like that like look how cute i am you
can't be mad at me
and i'm like you're right okay
we see you we see she got your baby
she's got her toys in her hands don't
think ever get the camera i know i can't
i can't do it i can't get it get it oh
man i can't do that
she had like this little orange she has
this little orange mousy and she had
like
she had it like in her hands like that
and she was like
when i was younger i was just based on
faith i thought it would all happen
automatically just from the [ __ ] that i
did
but uh
you guys will probably remember on the
show a few years back
when it called me back to the honky
motherland of mississippi
to watch over my father as he was
[ __ ] dying going through his [ __ ]
[ __ ] quadruple triple bypass
surgeries
and as i sat there or stood there
watching them cut my father apart into
[ __ ] pieces and him struggling for
life
and doing everything they could to
revive his [ __ ] little [ __ ]
mississippi [ __ ] ass
i thought to myself
all that [ __ ] was avoidable
every bit of that [ __ ] was avoidable
because he lived a sedentary lifestyle
watching [ __ ] meters and [ __ ] at the
damn water department he's not fat
though you're done he's not a little
skinny guy he's a little skinny guy a
little skinny guy who just didn't do a
whole hell of a lot physically and sat
around was raised from the
birth
with a bottle in his mouth with some
damn bacon grease in it i mean because
in mississippi you're raised on bacon
grease
i mean you have a couple strikes against
you from the outset when you're raised
in that situation you're gonna say
making grease into bottles just some
make him healthy well and that was even
extended to when i was a kid because i
kind of feel like uh you know i was
raised you know my parents raised me but
my grandparents had a large part in
raising me too yeah and because they
babysat me over the summer because my
parents worked and
uh southern
grandmas yeah uh were basically like you
need to like
eat right a lot
and if you don't eat a lot they think
there's something to matter with you and
what they're feeding you is not healthy
no
so jenny will tell you she will attest
she will testify
that was a life-changing event in me i
was different when i came back from that
yeah you were just like uh oh yeah we're
not yeah you were completely i was like
we're not immortal and you were gone for
two weeks and then you came back and
yeah i was like [ __ ] there are
repercussions of what we do
yeah and i started to see myself
physically sliding at that time and i
was like i'm fighting this [ __ ] so i
[ __ ] went into the gym and
did went on hrt and all kinds did
everything i could to try to [ __ ]
reverse
the neglect
and the [ __ ]
you can't fight forever but i don't care
about that
i'm in another competition
there are guys in their 70s that look
like they're in their 30s
and that's who i'm competing against and
you see and i want to i'm going to die
in my 80s probably 70s or 80s but i want
to die strong
all right i want that strong and i want
to i want to die looking good
and i want it to happen all at once from
something that
that i can't control
you know i mean if i could control it i
want to stop it if i can't control it
then let it be you know
[ __ ] i lived by the sword
i die by the sword or the scalpel
about the same thing and uh we'll just
see how it goes i'm not scared of death
i'm more scared of the suffering
yeah i kind of feel like that's the
actual dying is probably not the
shittiest part it's like you just don't
want to like feel like ass for like a
long time the suffering and watching
yourself fall apart yeah because i'm
watching my i'm watching my dad
just being helpless and and i knew he
hated every bit of it because he was a
very independent guy
my grandma went that went through that
as well she [ __ ] hated right being
she had stomach cancer and she really
she hated being a burden on anybody yeah
she didn't want to tell anybody she was
in pain she was just yeah she was just
kind of like look i'm just gonna like
keep on keeping on and not tell anybody
until she couldn't deny it anymore so
i'm watching my dad dying in a state of
humiliation i know he's humiliated
through all this you know he didn't die
though they revived him yeah he's still
alive he's still alive but he's still
dying yeah he's got cancer in his
thyroids the wounds from that surgery
never really healed up
and it had a lot to do with
how he was raised and diet and
um lifestyle
he'll he'll he doesn't have much left in
him
a lot of it had to do with diabetes okay
he's diabetic
man i'm glad i dodged that bullet
yeah that sucks my grandfather my
grandfather had that as well
his main thing was the diabetes
all right
and um
i feel bad for him uh but
none of us are permanent he had his time
and he spent it the way he wanted to
spend it okay
he doesn't have any regrets
he just i just know how he is he just
does not like to die he does not like
this dying weak thing you know what i
mean
he would have rather have been strong
and then just struck out
that's that's the way he went i kind of
feel like most people would probably
prefer that nobody wants to like go into
some long ass right horrible decline
right and i've and i'm not
i was never sensitive to death i've seen
a lot of dead people have handled
[ __ ]
body parts i held a beautiful girl's
head in my hand
i told that story too it looked
beautiful israeli girl
fantastic body decapitated i held her
hand hit her head in my hand
it was a weird sensation you know what i
mean but and but and i've seen busloads
as [ __ ] dead bodies
it's not the same being struck down is
not the same
as a long prolonged period of
humiliation
as your body fails you and there's
nothing you can do about it
yeah
yeah i mean i've been well you're not
recently with
feelings of suffocation
yeah because of how my stepdad went and
my dad said that he feels like he can't
breathe
and i've been waking up in the middle of
the night every now and then how many
times have i done that
it's just been a couple times well you
did it
two or three nights ago like you woke up
and it was kind of what was it like two
or three in the morning i think and you
know i'm not suffocating i'm afraid that
i'm suffocating which then and then i
have to
i have to battle that
at least i'm not seeing those monkeys
anymore but oh [ __ ] i forgot about that
right you're actually a lot better than
you used to be yeah
used to be i couldn't ever get like a
normal night's sleep because you were
always thrashing around and you were
always having nightmares because you
know your ptsd was like really bad yeah
for a long time like when you and me
first got together like it was really
bad like for a long time i thought that
i was being eaten by a sea of [ __ ]
monkeys that hated me
these little capuchin monkeys that were
eating me alive oh but i defeated the
monkeys
eventually yeah you haven't talked about
that in a long time honestly most of the
time
um
you seem to sleep pretty soundly yeah i
mean you do wake up sometimes like that
kind of stuff but it's pretty rare yeah
um you know i mean we both wake up and
because we're old now but we both wake
up in the middle of night because we
have to pee but you know
and sometimes if i wake up at two or
three in the morning i have to pee and
then sometimes i'm like thinking about
[ __ ] it's like oh i gotta do this
tomorrow and i gotta do that and then
like three hours have passed i'm still
[ __ ] awake uh you know that sucks but
you know um you're a lot better than you
used to be you don't like thrash around
like you used to you don't talk as much
in your sleep as you used to because
again that's something you used to keep
me awake a lot yeah talking to people in
your sleep you still do it every now and
then okay
but
not usually i mean because sometimes
i'll be laying there and i'm like half
awake and i'm just trying to go to sleep
and then like all of a sudden i'll hear
him like he'll kind of like move like
that and he'll just be like [ __ ] you
guys [ __ ] you guys like
like something like that and i know he's
like talking to somebody like in his
dream honestly oh what was that thing
you told me the other day you said you
woke up it was
like kind of it wasn't that early it was
i think it was five or six in the
morning
and you woke up and you you went no like
that and i was like what the [ __ ] oh i
saw pookie jump in the front yeah and
you said oh my god i just saw pookie
jump in the frying pan yeah in a frying
pan and i was like and i said no
and i was just kind of like oh i wish
you hadn't told me that i had this big
it wasn't a frying pan it's the pot
oh [ __ ] pot
and i had a bunch of oh and i was
dreaming that i had a bunch of [ __ ]
oil in the bottom of the pot and it was
[ __ ] sizzling and i put some garlic
in there and i wasn't watching and
pookie jumped in the pot oh no i
couldn't jump out of the pot did you
hear that she's sleeping and her [ __ ]
paws were sizzling
and every time i'd grab her
she'd [ __ ]
scratch me so i'm trying to get her out
of the pot and i woke up trying to get
her out of the pot yeah that one that
one bothered me
i have
i have these
it's part of the reason why i you know
my uh disability from va and everything
because
[ __ ] [ __ ] happened
i have these uncontrollable these
feelings of
uncontrollable helplessness
of things that i don't have anything to
do with like the cat jumping into the
pot
and i can't get the cat out you know
it's [ __ ] i have a lot of that
or i have nightmares like that too right
they're like they're they're images of
horror yeah is what they are you know
and i mean lately they don't have
anything to do with anything right yeah
well i mean especially since we've had
pookie because she's like she's like our
baby right um
so if i have nightmares i always have
like nightmares about something bad
happening to her oh we got mango sent us
a
super chat oh [ __ ] you're waiting oh
yeah i know well i was like i was
reading them thank you mango great
sidetracks great chat
on an f at party time b is back in the
centipede in the middle
they're talking about like you instead
of eating yeah they're like making that
but yeah so because i told you i don't
remember if i told this on the side
track show but one nightmare that i had
the other day and this was like
horrifying because it was so
realistic
i dreamed that i was sitting there at my
office computer like i do every day
and i dreamed that you came into my
office door as you do sometimes when you
want to tell me something
and you told me that pookie had died
okay and that woke me up at two or three
in the morning and i could not go back
to sleep because i was so upset
and
so don't listen to that pokey right
she's sleeping she's sleeping right
there like on her back and she she's
like this
yeah
somebody said that's right tom [ __ ]
uh oh [ __ ] people at the man ever eye
bar is moving matt t just says [ __ ] you
hear high bars moving what i borrow
evidently lost the [ __ ] gig there
[ __ ]
i knew i knew that wait what are you
looking at what are you looking at uh
little matt said that
oh you're looking at your listen to
messages now wait you're not talking
about i were you talking about manta
mori
or now
i might find out
that's a little map okay i need to go
check facebook later
and then um
cons telling me stuff about [ __ ] look
man i know made a no-hitter i don't talk
about but he's playing video games
gabriel says uh the better sense of
steven segal that was [ __ ] that's my
buddy there
then the uh i mean our old landlord is
[ __ ] um saying uh good luck with the
new house and [ __ ] happy that that's
that was great
they helped us out
yeah they're they were happy that they
unloaded one of their properties
hi pokey we own the other house behind
us it's just like this one we'll see if
that one's oh that's right i forgot
yeah they they own another they own a
bunch of houses like right now
uh
guys are in there talking about yeah
tommy men have to die looking good
i'm going to show you who i'm competing
to guess
against all right some people are saying
well i want to be like arnold
schwarzenegger and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] no by the time those guys hit
50 they didn't look that good because
they abused so many anabolics all right
you want to [ __ ] go for longevity all
right
this dude here 72 years old
all right
that's how you want to look at 72.
oh i'm competing with him
i mean nobody would ever know that that
dude was no he has a body of a
30-something year old well even his face
doesn't look like an older i mean he
looks
older but i if if i had to guess how old
that dude was i would say
maybe 50 maybe
now someone said well he's asian they
hide aged no
no
yeah he's chinese but um no if you were
to see it in hd
that is hrt
working out and uh the proper compounds
and you're replacing what normally is
lost in the body
and uh no you could look fat that he
okay look he won a competition
uh last year at 75 and he's unchanged
he still looks like this is old video of
him
he looks like that at 75 now
unchanged
that's what i want
and i don't care if i die at 75 as long
as i look like that at 75
and i'm telling you that [ __ ]
feels great
i'm 50 i feel like i'm 18.
okay hormone replacement
working out
proper diet
being a bad [ __ ] dropping a dick
on a [ __ ] there it is that's what you
need
okay
ian england says i used to have terrible
nightmares i started playing call of
duty and it for some reason gave me
power in my dreams i just started
shooting the stuff that was coming after
me well no i kind of feel like honestly
like video games might be good in that
regard because if you're having
nightmares because you feel like you
don't have any control over your
situation if you play video games it's
giving you control uh you know over a
simulated situation so that might
actually like be helpful you know what
i'm saying
i am it doesn't really
well i mean for but you know they'll
have a different effect on different
people obviously cheryl says what a
terrible nightmare i think she's talking
about like the pookie thing janet goes
wow she's talking about that 70 year old
chinese dude
[ __ ] cheryl goes drop those dicks
guys
[Laughter]
y'all are [ __ ] funny gabriel says
better than drunk sleeping my mom caught
my brother trying to pee in his dresser
drawer once when he was wasted dreaming
um
i mean i've gone to bed drunk many a
time but
i don't think i've ever done that though
and you've never done that what's that
like
like pee on like peeing in the closet or
something like that because you thought
it was someplace else i've never been
i'd i've been pretty drunk but i've
never been that drunk no you don't know
did i yeah that i forgot where i was
peeing you know what i mean
look at pookie
look at pookie
she's like what why she's like why
she's like she's like she's laying on
her back [ __ ] playing and looking
like what i see you
i see you
yeah
whenever i say i see you her your tail
wags you know what i see her a little
stumpy tail
i started like posting some videos about
her and somebody like commented like oh
my god she does look like a little bear
and i said that's really funny because
well the reason i started calling her
pookie because her official name is baby
cookie
um but i started calling her pookie
because she looks like a little bear she
looks like garfield's teddy bear and
pookie was garfield's teddy bear from
the old comic strip so that's what i
started calling her it's like oh she
looks like a little pooky and that's it
was kind of like a term of endearment
and then it just kind of became her name
but
i call her gummy bear sometimes too
because she lays on her back and she
like puts her little legs out like that
and she has she's a mix so she has
this kind of
wide little body like a little round
body and these tiny little short legs so
she puts her little legs out like that
and she looks exactly like a little
gummy bear and it's just like so [ __ ]
funny but uh you know she's cute as [ __ ]
you are cute as [ __ ] she knows she is
she's like what okay
um yeah i don't honestly uh caitlyn says
would you guys ever get into virtual
reality based games i don't know i might
i'm not a big gamer i guess just because
i like the idea of it i just never
i don't know i just i feel like i never
have time
um
tom games a lot but i don't really
i don't know i kind of feel like i want
to get into it but then i'm just kind of
like man i have so much other [ __ ] to do
it's like i've i have to read this book
i have to watch this movie i have to i
have to write a chapter of my book i
have to do this on the other thing and i
just feel like i never have time to do
it but it always seems like something
kind of fun to do though i don't know i
never got around to it um
you know
camp guy said i had that one uh probably
like a nightmare we're talking about oh
camp guy said anybody had the dream
where you're lost inside a huge office
building or entertainment complex and
trying to get back together with your
group or find the way out
i have a lot of dreams like that
um
i have dreams like that i usually have
dreams
like that
this is like kind of weird but if i'm
sleeping
and i have to pee in my sleep i will
start to dream that i'm in
a mall or a big complex or like some
like an abandoned mental hospital or
something like that and then i start
looking for a bathroom or i start
looking for other people and then
there's some reason that i can't use the
bathroom like it's really disgusting or
it's open and like people are watching
me or something like that which i think
that's like my brain's way of like
waking me up and making me go to the
actual bathroom i have dreams that i'm
in a mall and when i try to leave the
mall i end up back in another store and
it's like i've had that yeah i've had
this loop yeah i've had that one i go up
the escalator when i get to the top of
the escalator i've gone down and i'm
back on the [ __ ] first floor again
and i can't go anywhere i can't get out
of the damn ball i've had that yeah yeah
i kind of feel like i don't have
that many all the nightmares i have
nowadays are about something bad
happening to pookie
um
prior to that you would think that
somebody that's uh that watches as many
horror movies as me would have more
nightmares but i don't and honestly i
never have
i've had a few like [ __ ] doozies and
i turned those into short stories but
i've had so few that i can remember them
like you know i can count them on one
hand
i don't know why but
to be honest i know this is like weird
to say but i always kind of like wish
that i had more nightmares so i would
have like more inspiration for horror
[ __ ] i don't really know why
i don't have that many
um maybe it's because
i write horror stories i watch a lot of
horror movies
so
it's
i don't want to say it's like uh oh
i don't want to say it's like passe or
anything like that but
i'm just so immersed in it that it
doesn't
register
maybe i don't know what it is
there you go he's got his [ __ ] sucker
hat on they're asking me to morph into
vain
well where's your um where's your baby
mask is in the other room
what a hold on let me get bane now
because you you bought that yeah
he bought like the the luchadore
bane mask for that to he bought it to
like wear a mannequin you know
um
gabriel says ever since i've seen the
internet calling cats loafs i can't
unsee it my cat constantly looks like a
loaf of bread yeah i call it pookie like
little pooky loaf she's you're kind of
doing pokey laugh right now aren't you
she's looking at me like what i'm not
doing anything weird
yeah
she has a i have all her toys like in
this little pile right here and she's
just like really keeping up with us
i like the device machine good old ice
machine like a cheesecake god damn what
a time to be alive new ice machine is
kicking ass isn't it nice that we live
in the 21st century yeah and we have all
these like conveniences [ __ ]
conveniences and [ __ ]
i didn't even know they made those pants
she's like i'm sniffing all my toys and
seeing which ones are the toys
no one's going to take them polka i
promise those are yours we're not going
to take the toys
i'm not going to put the choker on
you're not chokers in the other room
what what you want to put your choker on
no i heard pookie go bro
yeah
what are you doing what are you talking
about if you get pokey's attention she
goes
like yeah she doesn't she doesn't really
meow as such
she whirs yeah she makes like a weird
whirring noise yeah
without opening her mouth they call it a
trill yeah she trills yeah it's like a
whole language that she it's common it's
common for a um that kind of cat yeah
it's a max
yeah
there we go
i like it i'm gonna do the danny trejo
[ __ ] uh bane
okay batman i know
i know where you are batman essay it's
i'm the mexican
i'm the mexican bane
next time you see me last time i broke
your face next time i'll break your soul
batman
certainly terrified yeah yeah yeah can
you breathe in that yeah okay
[Laughter]
just just wondering
[Applause]
pokey is looking at him like what is he
doing
i don't know either poke
next time her eyes are like next time
batman
oh pookie's not having it she's like
watching it like what what the [ __ ] is
going on
[Laughter]
tammy says pookie is saying put the
choker on
i don't know she is she's kind of like
over there going like looking at him
very nervously like what like what are
you doing daddy
you're you're being weird
uh caitlyn higgins says i have dreams
where my home had impossibly more rooms
than it should oh yeah it sounds like
house of leaves
and that led to completely different
places geographically and or in time
i had a dream one time i was in an
apartment
when i was in my apartment up in um
massachusetts
and opened up a closet
and [ __ ] i walked into the closet
when i turned around and i saw there's a
line of buttons
like an elevator and i pressed them in
the door shut and i [ __ ] the whole
closet dropped like 20 stories that
opened up it was an underground chasms
that one scared me
that one scared me that's pretty creepy
and my closet turned out to be an
elevator
from another era
see i l see that kind of [ __ ] yeah
that's the kind of [ __ ] i like in my
horror stories because
it's
mundane
uh it's something everybody can relate
to but it's like a little bit of skew
to me that's scarier than like [ __ ]
that's like way the [ __ ] out there you
know what i'm saying yeah i always kind
of like
so i kind of feel like like a lot of the
ideas from my horror stories came from
something that's like kind of
regular normal kind of life but then you
know for example hey i live in a house
and like have all these woods behind my
house and then there was a hurricane and
it blew all these trees out and then
suddenly there was this weird like
structure back there that i never knew
was back there it's like this weird
mysterious little house let's
investigate that so
[ __ ] like that's like creepier to me
than stuff that's kind of more
overt i guess
i don't know
um yeah psychological horror is the best
i agree
uh camp guy says i dreamed about eating
a giant marshmallow and when i woke up
my pillow is gone dude i've heard that
story
that's old [ __ ] bro i've heard that
story
[Laughter]
all right so you're just gonna wear that
now for now yeah off and off okay when i
feel like i'm gonna turn into bane i'm
gonna turn into bait
he's being a super villain yeah i'm
being upset he's being a super villain
spooky spooky come hang out with [ __ ]
super villains she's like busy she's
eating she's eating treats yeah
i wonder if she likes this dude i mean i
wonder if she likes those like meaty
ones i got her we'll see
i just saw him at the dollar general and
i thought well we'll see how that goes
there's still temptations they probably
still have that crack in them i'm not
really sure
can we talk about because i called this
[ __ ] show
gods and monsters can we please talk
about that boris karloff documentary go
ahead thank you
so
if you don't know if you have shutter
shutter just added
a documentary about boris karloff
and it's called what's it called the man
behind the monster i think it's called
and it's a little i will say it's a
little amateurish but it's actually like
it's informative it's really good like i
was really into like i'm just saying
amateurish in the sense of like the
editing and stuff
but
um you know it's not as good as the folk
horror one i can't stop plugging that
because that [ __ ] was amazing even
though it's like three and a half hours
long but i mean this one was
hour and a half something like that but
i love boris karloff so
i went to shutter last night because i
was like man i haven't chucked cheddar
in a while and i was just kind of like
oh well this is my [ __ ] [ __ ] sorted
for the night cause i [ __ ] love boris
karloff and honestly
watching that
it's a little bit all well it's a little
bit all over the place at first but then
they kind of like go into his history
and stuff and
he just seems like
a really great dude like him and vincent
price
seem like
sort of like horror royalty to me and
toward the end of the documentary they
were talking about
you know in their later years
uh you know some of those like variety
shows they used to do and they did one
that had both
boris karloff and vincent price on it
and they were like older at this point
and i'm like
i thought to myself how [ __ ] cool
would it have been
to hang
with boris karloff and vincent price who
were friends in real life
uh
on that [ __ ] set holy [ __ ]
i would give all of the money
to hang out with those [ __ ] dudes
back then
that would have been so [ __ ] cool
boris karloff seemed like i mean
vincent price too but boris carlos
seemed like here's his
trippy out when you think of boris
karloff what kind of dude you thinking
about you thinking about some
maybe like a british guy who's just like
uptight
or yes
he had some badass flicks i love the
black cat i think that's one of the best
yeah that's like one of my favorite i
mean other than frankenstein and bride
of frankenstein i think the black hat is
probably the black cat was the movie
that really pushed the boundaries and
they went wait wait no we can't have
this
necrophilia satanism well that was
before that was pre-hades yeah
they were like we can't have this [ __ ]
you want to see the black cat boris
karloff bellagosi
so good right that's so good if you look
at boris man you would think well what
is this this is
karloff his name is boris he must be
russian
no boris carlos was indian his dad was
from half indian davis from india's
mother was britain and and i did not
know i thought you're dealing with a
white guy
no no he's it all starts making sense
though when you look at his the roles
that he played
he played egyptians he played all these
exotic people chinese chinese people
he played foo manchu a couple times
which i want to see that i've never seen
that
i'm gonna see that one they said that
well that movie was unacceptable it was
great well at the time it was him i got
to see that at the time
go see it i mean they did that a lot
back then because they didn't have a lot
of quote unquote ethnic acts well they
didn't have chinese actors you had right
and
you want to pull in the audience you got
to and the weird thing too was that a
lot of actors that they sold as white
actors were actually not white no no
they're they're mixed race or mexican or
some other ethnic group but they didn't
want to tell anybody that
you know well there's something to be
said for that [ __ ] look
okay
the stage
is kind of like the carnival
it's a place of fantasy
sure
an actor really should have the freedom
to be
whatever role is called for
and you know what i mean
you should not be restricted to playing
people of your own race i don't believe
in that a real actor should be able to
play anybody it's part of an art
okay
uh example
in modern times
[ __ ] one of the best actors would a
[ __ ] american actor would have been
[ __ ] um
guy from midnight cowboy uh
wait justin hopper justin hoffman
doesn't happen could play anybody he's
jewish
but destin hoffman could play anybody
he can even play a woman
he could play a man dressed up as a
woman okay
he could he wanted to be he wanted to be
james bond
could dustin john hoffman play james
bond he's a jewish guy could dustin
hoffman play james bond
yeah i think he could
doesn't actually like to see that i
think he could he could do it because if
he could pull it off i think he could
pull it off acting in the theater is the
realm of faith back in the day back in
the day like he's old now but you know
yeah back in the day he could have
[ __ ] acting is the is the realm of
fantasy actors are professional
entertainers they're like magicians
they're they're liars
that's what you're doing
you're selling a person into a fantasy
and that's what that art is so
can you play a person of another race
yeah yeah you can that's what that craft
is about
all this [ __ ]
well depending on how far out i don't
think that if if there's a very large
gap between no
i'm just gonna say no
okay i'm just saying no no
this is a craft okay it is i agree with
that okay if this is a craft
you as an actor are supposed to deliver
a product a role it's supposed to be
entertainment
it's not reality it's art
okay
for instance
okay um
trying to [ __ ] put oh [ __ ]
a boy who did does all the damn i'm
drunk now so i can't remember
everybody's name yeah he's putting this
part part of my [ __ ] head well give
me a give me a clue give me his name
give me give me a hit give me a hint
re-animator
jeffrey combs jeffrey combs
i'm drunk too but i remember what's that
jeffrey cubs
wanted to play a role
that was a black a black character
would you want to see that yeah
yeah why not
let's see jeffrey collins play a black
character well let me see the context of
it first i don't really know i don't
know how no just [ __ ] you know i mean
it could be anything
i want to see that
because he's an actor he an actor is
like a carnival
entertainer now this is this is fantasy
okay sure
now i will say too
if you're going into [ __ ] like horror
comic books or something like that
um
i don't know i'm kind of like in the
middle about it it's like okay okay well
if the character is a certain race
um maybe you should get somebody that's
that actual race to play it but okay i'm
not buying him no
jeffrey comes
jeffrey comes
jeffrey cummins wants to play
spawn
wouldn't you want to see that
well i was a big old black dude i would
watch jeffrey combs do anything right
and i'm not sure it would work out but
he'd have i like him as a person
it would have to be jeffrey combs trying
to figure out how the hell he's going to
do spawn
because spawn was a big old well they'd
have to lag dude
commando who had returned from hell
as
as a superhero slash
dark a dark superhero okay
could jeffrey comes do that i would say
yeah he could do it he could he could do
it it would not be the spawn you're
thinking of
okay but yeah i would like to see that
but see
well the thing about it though it's
um
it's on a case-by-case basis i will say
because if you're talking about
um
a character that never existed in real
life like a superhero for example
um
you can do
a myriad different things with that
superhero if you want to because it's
not a real person you can have anybody
you want play that character and i'm not
yeah and i'm not going to get butt hurt
about it well that's something i'm
right um i think the problem arises when
you're having a pro having an actor play
somebody that was uh like a real
historical figure for example
um i don't think i think that's a little
more problematic sure you got black
british actresses playing [ __ ] and
blind and they're black
and blind was white
right but i don't know it's got to be
like i said it's on a case-by-case basis
i don't i don't um if i haven't seen it
i'm not going to get upset about it
because i haven't seen it
look i'm an ex-actor [ __ ] you know
what i mean i i i [ __ ] i said [ __ ]
that [ __ ] i walked away from it at an
early age all right i didn't really want
anything to do with it after that after
the i don't like that industry
but i do like that craft
acting
is a craft
it's not political
it's entertainment
it's just uh
it's a person trying to convince an
audience that there is something that
they're not
it's like magic
like a magician
well yeah like everybody is like
everybody understands that but i think
that uh the problem that people have
with particularly movies from like the
1920s or 1930s was that the reason that
white actors
were given the roles of like chinese
people or something was because they
were not hiring
chinese actors for various reasons
um so i think that's why people find it
a problem yeah but in the case of fu
manchu there weren't any famous chinese
actors and there weren't any chinese
christopher lee played fu manchu yeah
at one point and i will have to say even
though i love christopher lee somebody
asked me what my favorite christopher
lee movie was
uh
i don't know if i could pick um all of
the dracula movies are good i'm kind of
partial to dracula 80 1972
i know it's bad but i don't know i kind
of like that one
but the thing about it is that
i have to say that the fu manchu movie
that christopher lee was in
other than christopher lee being in it
that was probably like the worst movie i
ever saw i didn't i never saw it it was
on mystery science theater and honestly
that was the only episode i couldn't get
through do you remember even with the
jokes about do you remember the fiendish
plot of dr matt i do i do with uh
[ __ ] on the dude that played the pink
panther what was his name again [ __ ]
peter sellers peter sellers i loved that
movie as a kid i thought that she was
[ __ ] yeah i liked it it was obvious
that that was a white dude pretending to
be a chinese dude that was like very
common it was just pretend very common
just pretend you know what i mean it's
just
boris karloff played some chinese well
because
um
well like i said not here
i think tom didn't realize but yeah
boris karloff uh not really a white dude
he was no not a white he was mixed race
indian yeah indiana uh half white half
indian
and uh so and not indian like native
american but india for like from india
and i never would have known and so the
reason that and if you see pictures of
him because when we watched the
documentary they showed pictures of him
like from his school days
it was very clear
from the school pictures that he was not
a white kid yeah he's part indian and
that he got picked on um you know and
they kind of went into that they didn't
go into it a lot but a little bit
and so when he was started out acting
which he didn't do immediately like he
did some acting early
and then he was like you know he wasn't
really getting any roles so he went and
did like manual labor like he did okay
you know he worked on railroads and you
know [ __ ] like that
and then he uh got back into it like uh
stage acting and then he got into the
movies but i kind of feel like a lot of
his roles were
he would be given the quote-unquote
ethnic roles because he didn't look like
a white person
um so he played chinese dudes he played
egyptians he played like all kind of
like any kind of like ethnic role that
you had you would give it to boys yeah
you would give it to boris karloff until
frankenstein and then you know yeah
that's not exactly the way
they described it and that's not exactly
what the deal was
they
liked how he looked
because he could be anything he was kind
of neutral
you could darken him and he could look
like anything he could look like an
egyptian he could look like this or that
you could lighten him up and he could
look like a british guy which that's
very
that
in the acting craft that's very
important
if you
if you lightened him up
he actually just looked like he had a
very roman nose he was very grunkle
roman looking he
i didn't know that that was that that
guy was indian i thought he was a white
guy
that's what he seems like
you could darken him and he looked like
to me he looked like a white guy that
you darkened
but yeah that's just it didn't matter
this is
it was theater it's not realism it's
it's it's magic it's movie magic and
that helped him get roles
he was a great actor i would argue he
was a great entertainer that in some
ways uh his ethnicity was i think that
helped him yeah in some ways early on it
was a detriment but later i think it
helped him because he had a very
distinctive
look and a distinctive voice right um so
i think that i mean he ended up kind of
typecast because people wanted him to
play like villains and stuff like that
but
i mean that's better than getting no
working
and to be honest with you
i kind of feel like
white dudes that were kind of like
leading men type of roles
yeah they all kind of looked the same
and honestly and there's nothing wrong
with that like they were good looking
but
boris karloff
and [ __ ] everybody remembers
boris carlos unique nowadays
yeah because
he had something
different right and you wouldn't have
remembered karloffie if he
didn't have that indian influence and he
said
and he was a great actor oh yeah it was
a good act and uh and he seemed like a
just a nice man and you had he just
really seemed like it was i understand
that
the theater is very much like the
carnival they're selling fantasy to
people you have to be very versatile you
have to be
flamboyant and different you can't be
same
same you say
you have to have take what you have and
know how to sell that work it and work
it okay
and better if you have this unusual
better fits on you yeah and people have
this weird idea that the classics of the
silver screen during the 20s and 30s
were these lilly white anglo
american
no no you have no idea how many mexicans
were in that scene that you would not
know that that was a mexican well i mean
they changed their nations and kind of
like everything's fantasy yeah
everything was fantasy
and you changed your name to some exotic
[ __ ] flamboyant name
everything is [ __ ] fantasy fantasy
sold back then and
i actually like the old hollywood
because of that they're suspending
reality
and making a new reality it was the it
was the fantasy of the silver screen
where anyone could be anything
like like circus
it was it was very much like this yeah i
get that
all right that's what they were selling
and people buy that
i mean because boris karloff i don't
know if you guys know but
his real name is william pratt yeah yeah
carter these are all fake names that's
nice
and it's not like well we're trying to
be white no white people tried to be
non-white
emilio estevez was a white boy
okay
well a lot of these white people tried
to sound exotic by taking spanish names
and an italian well in the u.s
everything was everything was the
opposite of what it was it's really
weird
and watching the documentary about boris
karloff this really kind of came at a
stark relief yeah i was kind of like the
early days of hollywood they were very
concerned with making everybody as like
white as possible like we're like gonna
take like mexicans and give them white
names and like dye their hair red and
[ __ ] like they did with uh you know some
some actors but
it's weird because they wanted this
exotic kind of thing too going on so
it's kind of like they didn't really
know
and like i said a lot of the white actor
if you just had like this white bread
like handsome kind of [ __ ] going on
like yeah you could go far with that but
it had to make you more but there were a
lot of those
and
to stand out you almost kind of needed
some quote unquote ethnic kind of [ __ ]
but they didn't really want to
acknowledge it so it was like this
really weird like great
name or a [ __ ]
name so it's like this really weird like
like some castilian name like an aryan
spain spanish titan name it's like well
well like how can we just look at
ricardo montebron like how can we be
ethnic but not like
gross ethnic you know what i mean it's
like it was almost like that well now
what it was is that california and
[ __ ] tijuana were very close together
all right so that's not exotic from the
point of view of people that were in
hollywood yeah it had to be more than
that yeah okay that's what you so yeah
like something you're like eastern
european yeah yeah because you're like
some like dracula [ __ ] right
because in california all that's just
local sure so it has to be bigger than
that
so i know it's you know i'm [ __ ]
i was born in [ __ ] long beach
california i know that that scene too
[ __ ] tijuana was right there all
right
uh so you couldn't just
so that's not gonna impress somebody in
in in in hollywood because they're like
mexicans that's right that's not exotic
[ __ ] everybody's mexican everybody's
mexican so that that you know that's
what i'm saying like ricardo monteblond
coming at you like he's from [ __ ]
spain he's from madrid
no
[Laughter]
actually no he was from mexico city his
family was from from mexico city but he
wanted to be like but yeah now we're
going to take that [ __ ] back to the
[ __ ] hockey motherland right we're
going back to spain
back to spain because that was like
classier yeah because it's europe bigger
further away from america sure that's
what they're doing oh i know yeah
everyone's backstory was just kind of
like uh but if you look at the backstory
exaggerated yeah
and the original goth okay the original
god [ __ ] [ __ ] male and nermie also
known as elvira
with those eyebrows and all that [ __ ]
gear that she wore
well [ __ ] mexican girls wore that too
mexican girls in southern california
wore that too for a long time
but there's a there was a big
mexican
influence on the god in the early goth
culture that did that vice versa uh
one of the [ __ ] coolest [ __ ] god
girls of today is from mexico i [ __ ]
got her on my [ __ ] instagram she
looks like them santa muerte and [ __ ]
and doing
cholo goth is what she calls it mixing
goth and mexican stuff it's not as crazy
as it sounds if you're from those areas
it's really not it's not that crazy
i mean honestly
mexico and goth yeah there's a hand
seen in mexico oh yeah
okay i mean south america has always
been big on the goth thing yeah honestly
they got it right immediately
they're just like like oh yeah they're
listening to morrissey sure let me go
the rest of them right i mean so it's
it's not that weird and like i said the
whole mexican like the day of the dead
gods are into that it's it's a whole
thing
but yeah so
interestingly i kind of feel like
boris karloff
he was kind of like like i said he
seemed like a lovely
gentleman
um
[Music]
but
it's
it was just like really interesting to
me to watch that because it does kind of
seem like he got a lot of roles early as
villains because as i said his you know
his skull
is very distinctive he has a very
distinctive uh face
and he's very large uh he's he was a
tall dude so he's very like imposing so
he got a lot of roles as villains early
on so when he was the monster
and
it's weird too because i didn't realize
this
but when he was in frankenstein which
you would think i mean it did kind of
like make him into a star
but because he was under so much makeup
um
[Music]
movies that came later
even though they kind of like played up
him being in them because his name was
very big
they would like take pains to say oh
this isn't a horror movie or this isn't
you know what i mean it's
so it's almost kind of like they didn't
really want to
capitalize i don't know he fell into
this like weird gray area
he doesn't seem to have like been all
that resentful about it although he will
say
that
working on frankenstein with james whale
him and james whale did not
super get along let's say that uh they
kind of like soft pedaled it a little
bit like in the documentary but they
still like went into it
uh the
injuries that he sustained on
frankenstein and bride of frankenstein
um he got some back problems
doing that uh that
pretty much lasted the rest of his life
and might have been instrumental in
him
being one of the dudes that started the
screen actors guild i don't know if you
guys know that but
um
the screen actors guild you have to like
obviously the actors union that says you
can only work so many hours and like all
this other kind of stuff that was um
not just
boris karloff but he was one of the very
early
adopters of that and he was one of the
guys that started all that
so
if you're an actor and you're a member
of zag uh
thank boris karloff and others because
he got all the way into that but
honestly i will say and we were when we
were watching the documentary last night
i love jack pierce's makeup
on frankenstein it's beautiful it still
looks beautiful to this day look i have
a [ __ ] frankenstein [ __ ] back there
i will say yeah i will say
i
as much as i love that makeup
jack pierce's makeup on the mummy
edges it out i kind of feel like the
makeup on the mommy i love
i love frankenstein i love bride of
frankenstein
i love the mommy i love how [ __ ]
boris karloff
looked in that [ __ ] he looked [ __ ]
great as the mummy and as like the human
character oh my god
fantastic that is a fantastic fantastic
makeup i don't think that has ever been
topped
um even now if that was back in the
[ __ ] 1930s [ __ ]
so
so good
i mean that shot
of him like with the eyes and [ __ ] like
that god damn it's so [ __ ] good he
looks so [ __ ] good as the mommy i
love the mummy to be honest
um let's see where are we
this thing's [ __ ] kicking ass with
the ice i love this ice machine
hugo says christopher lee and dr tara's
house of horrors that's what we need to
like [ __ ]
review at some point
[Music]
yeah i mean anybody that's been around
here for any length of time
hey i'm really into like classic
universal monsters i'm really into that
hi sweetie
and boris karloff here's the cool thing
i love he was boris karloff was in all
these movies and he was like an actor
you know what i mean so
he was in frankenstein he was in brad
frankenstein he was in son of
frankenstein
and
you know that's good he probably got a
lot of money from that but he was more
interested in the craft
so
he went on he was on broadway it was an
arsenic and old lace they kind of spent
a lot of time on that in the documentary
which i appreciated and he was like
really into that and i thought it was
cool because in the 50s
when they started showing all those old
30s monster movies
uh on tv in the 50s and all these little
kids started getting into it
and so a whole new generation
got into
boris karloff and billy lugosi and like
basil rathbone and all those kind of
like people
and so people that grew up in that time
period were like really into it
and
i kind of feel like the the fact that
that happened made his like legend live
on because he died in like what 1969
right like yeah yeah he died in 1969.
okay tammy's saying that's why joel
brenner never told anybody who he really
was um i don't really know exactly what
you're talking about um joe brenner was
always the [ __ ] first of all he was the
original terminator
um i mean terminator was a [ __ ]
ripoff of fuel brenner from westworld
and now it was kind of oh of course it
was i mean and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
made bald sexy
and
and uh no um i asked my mom about yo
brenner
even back in her days because i was
talking about that [ __ ] this is years
back
back in her days your brandon little
[ __ ] was my size he made not
only did he make balls sexy he made
short sucks sex
short [ __ ] all right
yo brenner was like hot as [ __ ] guys
and the king and i fantastic [ __ ] oh i
love that movie right i love them um
no uh everybody knew that yo brenner was
mongolian or at least part mongolia
everybody did yeah
um
and
don't [ __ ] read in
don't [ __ ] think that [ __ ]
people didn't know what races were back
then they did
five people they did okay
uh my mom
what are you about to say tom no [ __ ]
uh
women of all races dated dudes of all
races including my mom okay well i mean
no one was really worried about it like
on that
down in the ground right no one's all
that they did not give a [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] no
okay um like i said as long as you're
fabulous and you're owning your [ __ ] and
you're funny and you're entertaining hot
dude hot woman you were getting action
it didn't matter what race you were
everybody knew that earth a kid was hot
little little black girl [ __ ] she was
hot as [ __ ] okay she's still hot okay
well she was her whole life i think
she's dead
um but no if you were hot didn't matter
[ __ ] oj was getting [ __ ]
tail way back in the [ __ ] 60s uh so
was sucking um
uh cream abdul jabbar was [ __ ] all
these dudes it didn't matter if you were
[ __ ] hot you were you were getting
some
i mean
okay
[Laughter]
famous hollywood and [ __ ] uh
vegas dudes okay who were not saying
raises her you know [ __ ]
oh what's that one that she
[ __ ] yeah my mom used to date well
she she did she dated robert goulet for
a while but he that's who i was thinking
it's white no it's the other one that
she did yeah i was gonna say that
he's native american oh
but
it didn't [ __ ] didn't matter they did
not matter do not listen well people
they didn't care
they only cared about what you looked
like and how much money you had and how
successful you were that's well
yeah and the thing about it though is
that status and clout
yeah yeah honestly like whatever
race or whatever whatever you were yeah
um nobody assumed anything if you had
money and you were good looking nobody
matters well nobody asked nobody asked
nobody asked well they didn't care no
that was that was bonus that was bonus
they thought that was more exotic if you
had money yeah you were right okay if
you were had money and you were
attractive and you were you were you had
status
if you were of a different race that was
actually a bonus
some people faked this and this goes
back centuries
it was like white women pretending to be
october it was the same [ __ ] thing
people like exotic [ __ ]
but you've got to be exotic that's the
thing you can't just coast on race
hey look at look at prince you think
prince was coasting on his race no
prince prince was a [ __ ] successful
because he was [ __ ] prince
i mean i don't know his [ __ ] prince
everybody like everybody can't do that
because that was prince's thing that's
[ __ ] prance
yeah but that's but that's kind of the
point that i'm trying to make is that
you just have to like
find what you are
right what what is awesome about you
and just
right project that right it doesn't
matter what it is no it doesn't look at
eddie murphy eddie murphy [ __ ] was
not coasting on his race
eddie murphy was successful because he
was [ __ ] eddie murphy okay well
because he was funny he was funny as
[ __ ] he looked great he's naturally
funny
and and which not a lot of people are
and people liked him everybody liked him
and and uh eddie had no problem
dating anybody he wanted [ __ ] date
that's
and
just because i'm a white guy all right
that doesn't mean i wasn't a huge fan of
eddie murphy me and all and me and my
[ __ ] friends back in
michigan were [ __ ] huge fans eddie
murphy and we were all white
okay
don't believe the [ __ ] hype okay
it's race is not really the main factor
it's who you are
okay it's like we love that [ __ ] dude
we thought he was cool as [ __ ]
and had he been white he wouldn't have
been as cool
he just wouldn't
it was just the way it was
look at pookie look at pogi
because you just take what you have and
you work with it and that's kind of what
entertainment was about that's what
hollywood but like i said this is what
the [ __ ] circus was about that's what
[ __ ] all that that was vaudeville was
about that it was take what you had
and and market that
and turn that into into something that
would
bring fame and fortune kind of like
gladiatorial combat in the arena you're
you're you're entertaining people and
you're trying to [ __ ]
get fame and fortune
and it it works man of course that works
it's the way people are
but to be honest i think that
uh you know the whole gestalt nowadays
i think that's more conducive to that
because it is kind of like you might get
a smaller audience than you would have
back in the old days because
everything's not as like
codified or as um
you know
uh you know everything's more diffused
but yeah everything's broken down into
right right which you know that's just
the way it is it's centralized like it
was right but you know uh i do kind of
feel like nowadays there's a lot more
avenues to get to like whatever
it is that you have going on right you
can find an audience for that because
everybody
right that is a creative person that you
know whatever it is you have going on
the world is not the same right it's a
lot and honestly i think that's like
better it's better it's more
democratized sure everybody is i'm into
it i like it i like it everybody is more
uh [ __ ] open to possibilities yeah
back in the day
the scene was shut off and very
corporate
very centralized and controlled
i i just look at youtubers and youtube
creators from across the spectrum
doesn't matter what race they are
everybody is having more fun and
everybody knows more about one another
you know
like there uh there's um
a black couple that i watch they're here
from florida it's uh lex and uh forever
husbands they're two married couples and
they do reaction videos they're from
tampa
and [ __ ] they got huge hits man
and they're aware of everything
it's not like it was back when we were
kids where everyone is in these little
pockets
everyone sees everyone now yeah
so it's becoming a little bit more
flexible no one's limited
no one's in the same boxes as they used
to be
so it it's gonna turn out it's gonna
turn out well like i said i'm not
bothered no honestly i
because we're all people and we're all
doing different things and we're all
trading and watching that's cool
like and you can honestly it's supposed
to be right i can go on youtube and find
like
way more content that i could ever watch
from like people that i'm interested in
watching right you know what i mean i
have like a watch later
uh you know playlist that is like hours
and hours and hours long
uh these are all p and they're all over
the [ __ ] place when we were kids we
only saw what they wanted to show us
yeah
the limited amount of channels
and everything was highly produced
[ __ ] kind of corporate [ __ ] crap
you didn't know what other people were
doing
just on the other side of your state
now everybody knows what everybody else
is doing
but see that's cool it's a lot better i
like that though
all right
and [ __ ] if you listen to the
corporate voices they tend to be more
full of [ __ ] than the [ __ ] personal
voices
because the big corporations that are
trying to sell products [ __ ] [ __ ]
them
lame
the way it really is is [ __ ]
individual creators that's a lot closer
to reality
everybody else always has [ __ ] money
they're trying to make in other ways
they have masters that they have to obey
but that's all it's all a changing
environment ten years from now you won't
recognize the planet it'll look very
different ten years from now
very different
kayla higgins says such a shame most
creature designs are done using cgi
instead of makeup or prosthetics yeah
even animatronics and puppeteering is
going away i don't know if i'd agree
with that because there's more [ __ ] out
there honestly i kind of think that
that's kind of what i thought in the
late 90s and early to mid 2000s um
everything seemed like it was going cgi
but there was a backlash yeah against
that because i wasn't the only person
that was like man this all looks like a
shitty video game so let's not do this
um you have a new generation
of horror fans or filmmakers
that are way more into
you know the art of filmmaking and their
you have like a whole new generation of
people doing
practical effects
i have seen in the last
five ten years
i've seen a lot more horror movies using
practical effects uh and very proud of
that fact so i do kind of feel like cgi
i well it's one of those things like
when photoshop first came out because
i'm a graphic designer so
this is kind of like uh you know my
wheelhouse when photoshop first came out
you saw a lot of people like abusing it
because
you know all these possibilities were
opened up
and i think the first the same thing
happened with uh cgi you could do
anything
and so they put it in every movie
probably why i'm not a big fan of horror
movies from
you know not across the board but
generally
90s early 2000s because they were very
cgi heavy but
going from maybe the mid to late 2000s
to
now
i do kind of feel like a new generation
has come up with a greater appreciation
of
70s 80s horror
uh practical effects and i do kind of
feel like that art form is coming back
because a lot of the uh horror movies
that i've seen recently have
actually used a lot of practical effects
and only use cgi very very minimally
so i do kind of feel like it's
i you know cgi does have a place
but
um
you know i think the fact the you know
the the thing of like people leaning on
it is maybe over
yeah i hope
um
you know because if you use practical
effects
it doesn't date cgi dates
uh as anyone that has watched a kind of
shitty horror movie the 90s will the
test
so
you know tammy jumps back and says
talking about joel brenner and says well
he told so many different stories nobody
really knew
what his background was as far as i can
remember uh yule brenner was a
part mongolian slash kind of kind of
russian
caucasian type guy
uh but does that actually matter it
doesn't he was a powerful [ __ ] dude
he had a [ __ ] powerful
personality around him he was a great
entertainer and actor
um
he he was gifted genetically gifted with
a certain kind of face
that looked that way and
damn he made money and he was just very
everybody loved him everybody loved him
but i think he was
mongolian mongolian and russian i think
is is is what is what he was
hugo brings up boris karloff in black
sabbath which i love that's mario baba
uh the terror
which
they talked about the terror extensively
in this documentary that we watched
roger corman
gotta love him
uh was always about
he loves making movies i'm not saying
that but
he never met like a [ __ ]
uh
money-saving device that he didn't
get into he's like look um
how many days do we pay to have this
actor on set
we finish shooting this movie let's have
him for two more days and we'll shoot
this other well i'm gonna shoot some
documentation for this other movie and
then we'll figure out what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is later on
uh that's what happened with the terror
he had boris karloff for
eight days or whatever it was
and he's like okay so we finished
shooting this movie in six days so we
still had boris karloff under contract
for two days so we just told him to like
film some scenes we didn't like have a
movie in mind necessarily we don't have
a script or anything like that but
we thought that later we could use all
this footage and we could put bars
karloff's name on it because it's
[ __ ] roger corman right which like i
said roger corman
um
like i said you gotta love the guy he's
[ __ ]
he knows the [ __ ] biz
uh
artistically maybe not the greatest
thing but
you know
he knew how to like squeeze all the
money out of the [ __ ] yeah is what i'm
saying tammy says well i don't mean that
it matters just that it made him sexy
yeah yeah you was a sexy guy he was um
he he was very handsome
he had a he was he like i said he was a
powerful little guy who didn't come off
as being a little guy but he was
he was my he was about my size five six
i believe it's about how tall he was
um
but he had a presence about himself and
he had a very
handsome face
um and him playing the terminator
uh
i must say it's the terminator he was
the original terminator westworld was
about the terminator when you go back
and look at that movie i mean
essentially that is that's what he is
yeah and uh and then his work in the
king and i
which is just that was just a [ __ ]
legendary movie so if you all haven't
seen the king and i i wish that was nice
i watched that in high school you're
wrong and you're bad
and not only are you wrong you're also
bad go back and watch kings oh my
goodness tom yeah yeah being bad you
know [ __ ] being wrong is one thing being
bad is something else
but you're wrong and you're bad you need
to go back and see uh king and i
uh and he plays a powerful romantic role
a lot of dancing
uh and yeah he had a uh uh yo brenner
was hot
he was hot yeah i'll agree very hot
and uh he was a man of his time and um
an upper echelon man of his time
but he he he had what he was born with
he knew how to play with it and he was
he had great talent and he was a good
dude real good dude
yeah man
dude was a smoker
died of [ __ ] cancer from [ __ ]
smoking man i remember honestly and this
isn't glad that i stopped smoking okay
because
and cut him down at a fairly early age i
think i might be older than him now
when he died didn't he do like
anti-smoking
commercial as he was dying yes yeah
i'm neil branner and i'm like dying yeah
he had like the [ __ ] y'all can check
it for me but i think i i don't even
think he was 50 years old when he died i
don't remember how old he was but i
remember seeing those commercials yeah
where
it's like yeah i'm yo brenner i used to
be like super famous but i smoked my
whole life and now i have like [ __ ]
cancer yeah and yeah it was like this
they hold they did this whole thing of
like commercials i remember that
that's like that's [ __ ] up
but yeah so
uh we're talking about different kinds
of men out there and you can [ __ ]
well like i said everybody has their own
kind of thing right
to
yeah you can there and it doesn't really
matter your race if you if you're
everybody has their own thing and you
know how to play it and you know how to
do this and that
and you have talent
then you're gonna rise to the top it's
not we're not living in this [ __ ]
racist world like people want you to
think you are no people buy the people
that they like and the products from the
people that they like
the race doesn't matter
look at the rock i would he's polynesian
isn't he wouldn't you say he's
polynesian
that [ __ ] is hot as [ __ ] he's
the number one dude i mean polynesia
what is he's an islander
okay you don't think of that as some
kind of
as a as a as an identity of some hot
[ __ ] he's hot as [ __ ] coming out
of nowhere
just being a leading man in all these
action movies
taking what arnold laid down and [ __ ]
better than arnold and [ __ ] i grew up
in that arnold schwarzenegger generation
and i'm going to say no the rock is
better than arnold
well the rock seems like a nicer dude
than the arnold yeah
yeah gonna say even though i like arnold
it's just that over over the years
as things changed
no man the rock is better than arnold
you know even though they aren't arnold
had a [ __ ] huge fan
of the arnold's move
i'm gonna call him the arnold
[ __ ] of the arnold's movies [ __ ]
maniac says the rock is black and samoan
he's black and samoan
so it's like a polynesia type thing an
islander
that [ __ ] is the [ __ ]
okay well he just seems like a
delightful person right of course from
my point of view he just seems like i do
i want to hang out with that dude yes i
would like to hang out with that dude
he's he's going to be in the new [ __ ]
superman he seems super fun
i've seen he seems like a nicer clips
from a new superman movie he's going to
be in and it [ __ ] looked good and
he's going to be in blackadder which has
something to do with shazam which i want
to say i love black adam black adam not
black or that's because
because i'm a huge fan of shazam i
[ __ ] love the shazam movie
um
and uh no no
and i always like the rock
like i said it's not so much like him
being like a muscly dude he just seems
like a nice man yeah that's what i was
saying on he just seems like
he's kind of a geek which i'm into that
and he seems like very genuine
you know what i mean well you see
when i was a kid coming up watching
conan and [ __ ] um predator which
great [ __ ] movies [ __ ] um
commando
the the only thing the only game in town
was arnie at that time when you talk
about size and that that was it
well yeah it wasn't really a big thing
back
back then yeah it wasn't big i mean it
was a big thing but for me being a boy i
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] okay i was like
that's [ __ ] great but there weren't
as many
people to look up to as what i'm saying
it was kind of like oh yeah well uh it
was a smaller
show
that's what i meant but no arnie was the
[ __ ]
but when i looked at the rock i was like
well there's a lot of stuff that arnold
[ __ ] kind of fell short on
you know what i mean arnold wasn't very
funny
he wasn't very uh [ __ ] likable in
terms of [ __ ] he never seemed like a
real person
he was always kind of
robotic his acting
then the rock shows up and i'm like oh
yeah
yeah okay
arnie could have been like this he's
already
the rock is giving you this kind of
broader spectrum a little bit of like
yeah he's a big like muscle dude if
you're into that but he also seems like
a genuine
person he's like really into
like i said he's like you know he's
really geeky and dorky and like that's
cool from
this as a straight man in front of my my
gay friends like zach okay as a straight
man i say this
okay
um
arnie never really [ __ ] kind of hit
me as like any kind of sexuality he was
not a sexy guy
no he's not
he's absolutely not but when the rocks
around i can understand it's a little
more it's like sexier you would think
that i like i could i could honor i
could see women into that
you know what i mean because he has
something else yeah
right it's not just because here's the
thing right i mean like from a female
point of view
uh you know
you're like bodybuilding and all that's
fine
but that's like just
an aesthetic thing and it's like yeah
yeah okay whatever that's cool but it's
like it's kind of like after a while
it's that's not all that interesting
yeah you don't
are you an interesting person are you a
cool person are you funny or are you
nice are you are you something else
other than that
me as a straight heterosexual white male
is looking at arnie going
you don't have that feeling that arnie's
going to steal your girlfriend
you look at [ __ ] the wrong he's not
going to steal your girl yeah you look
at the rock and you're going oh now the
rock the rock might steal your
girlfriend because that motherfucker's
got some charm behind him that's what i
mean
honestly even if well here's the thing
yeah the thing about the rock is that
even if he didn't look like that he
would still be a cool girl he would
still be he would still be able to like
pull some trim because he
he's a cool dude right that's that's i'm
picking that up also that's what i'm
saying i'm picking that up arnie
is kind of like he was kind of cold and
ro and clay
it's like he looked good like
aesthetically yeah but but
you wouldn't want to hang out with him
or have sex with him or any like not
really kind of kind of an artificial
feel to the guy
right
he seems like
and i'm not you know i'm not [ __ ] it
just seems a little bit cold he doesn't
seem like a real person to me kind of
like an artificial person right but
whereas the rock and roll honestly
with the smell with the rock is cooking
go ahead baby take that [ __ ] off i'm
gonna be here once let me put my jacket
up hold on grab my glasses i'll be right
there in a second but you're looking
good baby i'm gonna dive into this [ __ ]
you were burying my children tonight
that's the kind of that's the kind of
way man i'm [ __ ] seeing there well
see
i'm like stepping back i think that's
what people well that's what people are
responding to it's not so much the
physical thing because arnie has that
too right yeah um if all you have is
that yeah then that is a very very very
very limited spec yeah it's kind of
limited right um if you have that too
that's good but
honestly people are more responding to
your personality yeah
um if you are somebody that's fun and
somebody let people want to be around
yeah uh and you look good
then that's like a bonus but you don't
have to look like in arnold if he looks
like if he didn't look like that the
rock if he didn't look like that
um
he would still have he would still get
some action he would still get a lot of
action yeah because he's a very charming
right
funny like he has a good personality in
in arnold's defense
arnold was a product of his time
the movies themselves weren't like that
it was it was a little more formal back
then is kind of what it was
uh they it made for good movies
i made for good action movies it didn't
make for good romance movies you know
what i'm talking about
so i i i can't even even nowadays i
can't even really no i can't think of
him in that
way
it's weird and
everything i've been able to read about
arnold i've never met him i don't know
the guy uh
he kind of knew that he kind of knew
that he was not a sexy he did
yeah i mean i will give him that he did
actually know that he that that was not
his from whatever wheelhouse from what
i've heard in person
arnie had a lot got pulled a lot for him
but it was it was the movies of the day
and the way the machine was and he's not
an actor he was the bodybuilder who
ended up in acting
the rock was an actor because [ __ ]
wrestling it was an acting job it's like
the carnival
you know so it's it's a different
it was a different business
from from the very beginning the rock
acted
he got big after he was an actor
and i think like i said way
right because his personality came first
came first right and like i said
everybody that i have read about that
knows that dude said he is just a
delightful human being
and honestly if you're a delightful
human being and look like the rock yeah
you will go far yeah now here's my
caveat to that
the rock is also a character i could
tell he goes into the rock mode well
sure everybody does that that's just the
way it is that's just i mean i do well i
don't know if i do that like to somehow
everyone kind of does that to a certain
we don't do that to that much of an
extent because honestly what you see on
the live stream this is pretty much what
we're like in real life but
you do kind of have to put on some [ __ ]
you know for the public
so to a lesser extent i get it but i do
kind of feel like
i don't know i feel like the reason that
people like the rock is just because
he just seems like a good dude
yeah he looks like that that helps
but if you're a good dude and you also
look like that
you can't really fail to be honest with
you
you know what i'm saying it's just
you're not to fail um
let's see
[Music]
damn y'all still going yeah we are for
whatever reason i don't know how long
we've been on
over four hours holy crap
we haven't even like started a fight yet
awesome
but yeah i was kind of like
seriously if you have shutter
watch the documentary about boris
karloff like i said it's
production wise it's a little amateurish
but
it's fine it's fine
um
honestly i didn't mind at all because
i [ __ ] love boris karloff i love
30s horror i love all that kind of [ __ ]
i love all the old universal movies i
love all that [ __ ] i love silent films i
love all that stuff
anything about old hollywood
i'm super into that so if you like that
stuff then please watch that because
it's really really good oh [ __ ] no no no
we didn't go to zero we didn't get a
zero come on come on one more it's
orange that's red it's orange it's red
it's orange
it's yellow okay it's green okay
how long have we been streaming
four hours okay it's almost time to shut
the [ __ ] down anyway
are you gonna make four hours food i can
make it something to eat yeah sure
look at pookie what is she doing she's
collapsing over there but she's
she's sitting in her pile of toys
yeah and she's like why why why are you
like looking at me now then they're
talking [ __ ] about the rock and the
batista is much funnier batista is not
[ __ ] funny well
he can be funny yeah i've seen him be
funny um i don't mind him i just like
i'm i'm not you know he he's he's a
great bond
yeah
he's cool uh have we seen i
do you remember we kept going to the
theater and we kept seeing the trailer
for my spy
yeah which dave bautista was in
um which kind of looked funny i don't
know if it was good but i haven't heard
anybody talk about it so i don't really
know
but i don't have any i don't have any
animus
against dave bautista you want another
drink but sure why not
but
i don't know
like i said
the rock just seems like i think the
reason that a lot of people like him not
just because he's a bodybuilder and how
he looks and stuff like that because he
seems like a
a delightful human being
people want to hang out with people
that are
fun and awesome
nobody wants to hang out with people
that are
douches or
you know
not fun to hang out with
so i kind of feel like that's
where his charm comes from
and
that charm like exudes like into every
single role that he does
so
honestly
i'll pretty much watch anything that he
said if you guys have not seen fighting
with my family please watch it it's
really really good
it's really good
uh
batista's the delight i do actually like
him and a lot of stuff but i haven't
seen him in as much stuff
as i've seen the rockin
but he is also he's funny as well
camp guy says oh you talking about oh
we're talking about chinatown
uh i think they actually cut thank you
well you can put it on the coaster
i don't know where he went to
the rock is a taurus
i don't know what that means i'm not
like really up on my
astrology i'm a libra what does that
mean
i'm a libra and tom is a cancer
danny roland goes face reminds me
of wolf
with jack nicholson
i haven't seen that a long time
wait was michelle pfeiffer in that
or am i thinking of witches of eastwick
if you guys haven't seen
one of these days i want to re-watch
witches of eastwig i don't know if it'll
be as good i read the novel as well
which is by john f dyke
uh the novel is a lot different than the
movie there's a whole other character in
the novel that they
left out of the movie so i will say that
um
but i liked the movie i think it came
out in 87.
um
i don't know
jack nicholson played the devil in it
if you guys didn't know
but you know
just saying
mango says the rock rocks
i would not be his friend though
the rock rocks i would not be his friend
though
why not
i wouldn't hang out with the rock no
i've seen the rock pull up to [ __ ]
tour buses and go hey everybody you know
where the rock lives and they're like
yeah yeah yeah he you know
and uh i follow him on like i said he
seems like an instagram he's he's he's
working his crowd
no he he's good
he's good i don't even care if the [ __ ]
is
authentic or not he's working his crowd
and um
having an acting background i think he's
[ __ ] work i think he's he's authentic
well he really does like his fans and to
be yeah he really is a good guy i mean
to be honest with you he never struck me
as anything other than i think he is
good guys sure he seems like a good dude
yeah
would he steal your girlfriend
yeah he was still your girlfriend well
he's not that kind of guy where he's not
going to leave your girlfriend alone but
yeah he's still your girlfriend he
better [ __ ] but the [ __ ]
fishes and he has his own little house
i'm sure he's got his own girlfriend he
doesn't need to steal your girlfriend
okay but i'm just saying you know
he's famous he's got a lot of money and
he's can we talk a little bit though he
knows he's making money off of fans sure
he appreciates his fans
um
every project that he's [ __ ] helped
fund like shazam i [ __ ] liked it i
think i think he's a good dude and i
think he's a good entertainer he's a
great entertainer
especially for this time
we're not living in a time where there's
lots of [ __ ] talent okay we're just
not
um well no there is there's probably
like too much town yeah it's just so is
this
but there's the studio well the problem
is there's so many talented people
uh that
honestly i can't keep up
part of it is the studio system well
yeah but i'm not concerned about that
right
i'm just kind of like
he's a good entertainer he's an
entertainer he's a great entertainer but
the thing about it though let me go back
a sec
because you have this thing it's like oh
is the rock going to steal your
girlfriend
this whole like steal your girlfriend
thing
of course the greatest tactics of course
the soul is still your girlfriend thing
that's a little bit
you're acting like your girlfriend
didn't like want to leave
you know what i'm saying no one can
steal
your girlfriend it was a hypothetical
state it was a statement no one can
steal your girlfriend situation
if some dude comes along
and whoever you're dating at the time
goes like all right
uh okay
steal your girl the reason why i'm
saying she chose to go with the reason
why i'm saying that is because i [ __ ]
remember
reading
okay and hearing about rumors
about arnold schwarzenegger even back in
the 80s
that arnold was the kind of guy
that would [ __ ] your girlfriend
okay
but like i said he's that kind of guy
it's like your girlfriend being looking
at him too much he's going to come up
with me and we'll go with you
but like i said then he [ __ ] your
girlfriend and then he gives her back to
you
that that was easy that was that was the
kind the rate was that was what you were
dealing with but the reason that i'm
having a problem with that
the reason that i'm having a problem
with that
i can't help but i'm just
okay now i'm not gonna do an
go ahead go inaudib the reason that i'm
having a problem with that is because it
assumes yeah that your girlfriend does
not have any agency of her own
[Laughter]
i'm just saying you're just a sick dude
that would do that no i'm not even i'm
not gonna entertain the logic behind it
okay you're trying to logic i'm not i'm
not even gonna i'm not even gonna try to
logic another one that would do that was
[ __ ] evil knievel
evil
[Music]
evil
will [ __ ] your girlfriend then give her
back to you
look
[Laughter]
and this this has been verified by evil
himself
if you had a girlfriend
that was willing to go [ __ ] another dude
yeah and then come back to you
you did not have that girl amber knievel
was
and then he would show back up with her
because
here i'm done with her
that's
the kind of dude go ahead i i i'm doing
where they're going go ahead that's the
kind of dude that was by his own
admission
whether or not he lied or not but yeah
that's the kind of i could imagine that
though
but as i said this whole uh gestalt yeah
uh
that presupposes
that women don't have any choice in the
matter no i think they had the choice in
the matter but he still he would
monopolize on that too
you know but like i'm saying look
no one steals anyone from anybody
no one does that okay uh
we have i'm i'm a girl i have like
[ __ ] choices of my own
if you want to like [ __ ] another dude
then that's what happens
uh there must be some reason why that
happened
no one can steal
a girl from
him she willingly she willingly did that
[ __ ] yeah uh probably because of some
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] you did i'm just i'm
just repeating i'm just repeating the
stories that i but like i said
by repeating the stories
as i said that presupposes
that women don't have any choice in the
matter
all right so so how long have you been
how long have been gone uh i don't know
four hours a night
what about you but i'm ready to get
something to eat
you hungry jenny's looking annoyed yeah
i ain't worried about [ __ ] what who
is this what cheryl well oh [ __ ] here
she's been
bitching all night
cheryl why are you complaining
she's not annoyed i'm just talking about
i am kind of no you're not right
well you didn't ask me did you are you
annoyed
why are you annoyed
because you're assuming i'm not assuming
anything
you are i'm just going on i'm just going
based upon what [ __ ] he said himself
well you're going you're basing
something on something a dude said that
is
back in the old days when they didn't
actually consider that women had their
own agency you're trying to no they
women did have that agency i'm not
saying they did
but you know i mean dude the whole
concept dude
bro like look i'm not going to do you
girl the whole concept is stealing even
though your girlfriend a girl from
somebody is there's a certain bro level
to where you're assuming agency
i'm just saying you're assuming alive
bro level where do we go look man your
girlfriend wants me to hit this
but based upon our bro level here i'm
not going to hit your girlfriend okay
i'm not going to well gosh i'm mad i
know how they are yeah
you're so magnetic this time
and i know she's trying to get baggage
you so i'm not gonna do this
no i'm just i
i'm just [ __ ] around look um
what about you but it's time for us to
get something to eat i'm [ __ ]
starving you hungry
yeah okay okay
cheryl says it's going downhill man [ __ ]
cheryl and then cheryl says she's gonna
beat him i probably will later cheryl's
awful [ __ ]
sure you're full of [ __ ]
she's not she's up in canada beautiful
[ __ ]
why are you being that way not being
anywhere
uh you are being away
you're being away
he's you're being the way that you're
with yeah you're always being that way
i gotta be that way okay
he can't help it yeah he can't help it
you guys second nature
[Laughter]
cheryl said it's all good sorry tom i'm
well like i said he kind of like is
coming from a place and like i said he's
never been a woman
uh
[Music]
and so he doesn't understand i kind of
feel like i don't know
they don't i kind of feel like they
don't really realize that like we're a
person like we don't that we have like
our own [ __ ]
thoughts and feelings about things i
don't know i kind of feel like there is
kind of this thing among dudes like oh
you stole my girlfriend or so i'm like
you can't steal another person's
girlfriend um
that woman
willingly
[ __ ] this other dude
i'm not saying that's good
i'm just saying
she has agency also
um so i kind of feel like the whole
gestalt of like i stole this person's
girlfriend or whatever
that kind of like presupposes
that
that presupposes that the girl doesn't
have like any agency you know what i'm
saying
like you talked her into it i'm like no
she did it willingly
she's an adult so
you know
i know you don't take any girl things
seriously
i'm hungry
okay you ready
i guess okay let's go ahead and shut it
down what do you want to eat
oscar says no one can steal a girl she
can only do it willingly is it yeah
as if that makes it better it doesn't
make it better i'm just saying that
that's how they are don't
don't blame it on the dude
if you're
no i'm just i'm answering go ahead
uh if your girl
[ __ ] another dude yeah uh she wanted to
do that yeah exactly i mean don't blame
i mean you can blame the dude if you
want to but don't blame the dude it's
like oh he talked her into it it's like
look the woman she's an adult she's not
a child yeah um she did that willingly
probably because of something you did i
don't know maybe yeah it could have been
that guy or another one or another one
or another one that's what i mean i
don't know the top one is the one that
did it right yeah okay uh nobody can
steal anybody else's anybody uh do you
want to eat
i don't know okay i don't know just
don't ask me right
all right so
uh what is it it's friday right yes
right all right so tomorrow
i'm gonna sleep in god damn it
ben says think like uh think like animal
in the puppets
[Music]
carry him off to your cave look at pokey
yeah what you doing pokey pants
look at pokey
say hi to everybody poke
she's so hungry are you hungry
she's not hungry i got like a phone okay
i dumped a bunch did you give her any of
those treats no yeah okay we'll see how
that goes i got her some like new meat
sticks for tomorrow we'll see how that
goes should have been going on for four
hours it has well four hours and 25
minutes
oh
she's like all right i'll put it out
bye
all right so we will see you guys on
sunday probably we'll talk about
enemy mine because we watched that
last night or the night before
and so we wanted to kind of talk about
that uh so we'll probably talk about
that sunday we wanted to kind of do like
enemy mine and then
hunter prey
but honestly hunter prey is like really
really hard to find
legally i will say so
we'll see how it goes but we'll we might
talk about enemy mine on sunday but
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
until we see you guys on sunday
afternoon thank you everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we will see you guys on sunday afternoon
bye